hey you guys it's the friday before
halloween yep i'm so excited yeah we had
we had to uh restart the thing
yeah when our just little thing was on
our little pre-game thing yes it started
to show red like it was going too slow
might have had something to throw vpn
yeah i'm not really sure if that's what
was affecting it because like i said i
kind of feel like i didn't have nordvpn
running for the last few times because i
hadn't updated it and then i updated it
the other day and so it was running and
then
as soon as we started up it kept going
red orange red orange red orange and i
was like uh-oh yeah that's why i
restarted it but it seems to be green
now i'm green now hopefully it's okay
well hi everybody can you hear us i hope
so i just gotta get done drinking this
this is my protein drink
not like you didn't have like a really
long time to drink that before the show
started
i just thought about it because i didn't
want it i didn't want to drink on an
empty stomach
well maybe we ate earlier right
yeah
oh did you leave it did you close it
yeah
oh okay she was just making she was
scratching
she's probably scratching on that
cabinet sure for some reason she's like
fascinated by
the lower bathroom cabinet so she knows
there's nothing in there
but
and she figured out how to open them oh
she also figured out how to open
the bedroom closet too
last night
i think that it was kind of like cracked
open slightly but she's i guess she's
getting strong it's all those
temptations are making her strong
because she actually she's not we keep
it closed because she really really
likes to tear up tom's boots yeah she
[ __ ] rapes my boobs
and it's her favorite thing and she
knows she's not supposed to do it
because like she always does it like
when tom's uh kind of looking away and
then she just sneaks over there and goes
and then he's like i hear you and she's
like oh [ __ ] it wasn't me i didn't do it
and then like you know so we so we keep
the boots locked up in the closet but
she figured out how to open it it's one
of those ones that like you pull apart
like that so she was just like she'll go
up to the heel and lay down and flat try
to hide
i'm just she'll tear the back of any
[ __ ] heel up she loves it and i'll be
like hey and she's like i wasn't doing
it i wasn't doing it
you didn't see that yeah you were doing
it
she's like i forgot that daddy can hear
yeah
she poor guys so today is friday it's
another
friday it's halloween weekend
and tonight is our side track show
which is basically an open lines friday
aaron says where's tom's costume this is
my costume i'm dressed like an [ __ ]
that's why you know what i was going to
say it so i'm glad that you said it
first
[Laughter]
i was going to say well since i did my
little kind of cheap jack wednesday
adams thing i'm i'm the old geeky
wednesday adams uh you can take your hat
off and be uncle fester sort of yeah
i'm like one of those new harkonnens
okay there you go i'm like i'm the deaf
dude close the [ __ ] him out
close your mouth
oh man
[Laughter]
danny rolling ghostface says just saw
antlers for free it was decent
uh so okay yeah i'll have to go see it
this week i want to see that and i want
to see last night in soho i can't decide
which one i want to see more i want to
see both of them
but
i don't know maybe we'll go tomorrow and
see one although it'll probably be
crowded
maybe not though
maybe not man that needs to be stirred
what did you do with it oh you got pork
that you [ __ ] up your drink
yeah gram there's hammer said you could
be mr clean yeah oh [ __ ] i don't even
think of that actually all you need for
that white outfit yeah he just wears
like a white like a wife beater
thing right no it's a t-shirt right it's
not a white shirt and white jeans
and you could have had one because i
think we have zombies
oh yeah
i could have like loaned you an earring
i don't think i have one like is that
like a pirate one you could have and
don't we have a couple of those magic
erasers like under the kitchen sink you
could have just held up the magic race
[Laughter]
i don't get it
you don't know what is it mr clean do
you know those magic erasers
it's like a it's like a cleaning spongy
thing but it's kind of like it's got the
mr clean whatever
brazil or something or no that's no it's
recent yeah i'm pretty sure we haven't
seen how much tv in [ __ ] 10 15 years
almost well i'm pretty sure that it's
underwater neither have i but even i
know what those are because i you know
they um i think we have some actually
a little white things like styrofoam
sort of like i said it's like a scrubby
it's like a scrubby thing but it has
like the the stuff already and his ear
looks like people are starting to show
up
oh yeah they're piling in the front door
dermot says loved your review of the
witches thank you just watch the movie
now first time since 1990. yeah i think
i'd i mean i've seen it a bunch of times
because
i feel like it was on a cable uh a [ __ ]
ton like back in the 90s
and
i just
you know i think i said it on that
review but it's like i love all of those
like horror movies that are made for
kids that movie is [ __ ] up even though
it's a kid's movie yeah um what's his
name october 8th saying i got a cool
snake t-shirt yeah it's a snake pliskin
shirt
me and jenny make them this is my
concept jenny executed design we make
them here
and uh we'll send you to them in your
size for a 20 super chat i got this
full-size vert and then i got the half
size which is small too which is smaller
but they both look good
but uh for a 20 super chat we'll send it
to you delivered uh let's get your
information after the or uh
after the show
i mean and i know that i know we have to
do a canon one and we have to do the
other but you know like i said i think a
bit one i've been so busy and two
after doing those absolution shirts and
being like right down to the wire with
that and they all got behind and
everything and i was just kind of like
i'm just so overwhelmed at this moment
bee's nest is jocking me on those he
wants
abc or excuse me ocp from robocop it's
it's a really good looking shirt
and uh canon films
that's another going to be a really good
one i've already seen the designs we
have the designs just got to execute it
got to get a new frame and i got to make
got to make a screen and everything and
um
it was those were his ideas actually i
think i came up with canon he came up
with ocp yeah because i've been i
wouldn't wanting to do a canon one for a
long time because i did the logo like a
long time ago yeah
when you guys see the canon logo you
guys are going to want to buy that one
i'm pretty sure it's good
um
if you guys don't know who can canon
films was just a
in indie film studio that [ __ ] made
cheesy ass action flicks but some real
classics too canon i always just
i just always associate with them with
chuck norris movies
but i mean they made a [ __ ] ton more
stuff than that but i was always
associated i think they also did like
death wish four or something that she
did they might have yeah they did what
they did mostly action movies i think
they did did they do horror movies too i
kind of feel like maybe they did but
like i think that action movies were
like kind of b and c to your action
because where the one said what's that
they were best known for there was
another really good studio that had a
cool logo i want to do what was it
called coca-cola
what was the name of that [ __ ] studio
oh yeah corellico
i think it was corral
head or carol coe carroll coach c-a-r-r
yeah i know i can see it in my brain but
i can't we need to do one of that too
that was some other [ __ ] b and c
movies that were really good
i don't know what
[ __ ] terminator wasn't a carol co was
it t1
ooh
you know what it might have been now
that i'm thinking about it i think it
might have been danny rowling says
american ninja was canon films yeah
yeah and of course it's private domain
because all that shit's gone now
well yeah i mean i still wouldn't public
demand yeah i mean i still wouldn't
that's the thing like public domain like
all this kind of stuff is
a little bit iffy because even though
like if there's a logo and the company
isn't around anymore you don't really
actually know if you don't have the
rights to it really well yeah you don't
know if actually somebody bought that
right company
and is like so i wouldn't risk it but i
mean if you're making it at home and
just saying yeah it's not mass
production they're right profs they're
one-offs for fans and it's not like
you're making millions of dollars why
don't we make a couple bucks make five
bucks off of them
yeah because i mean by the yeah because
i mean by the time we ship them and
print them and yeah you know and i have
to we have to make a frame and or a
screen and that's bootleg as [ __ ] it is
that's bootleg as [ __ ] because we know
that that's a [ __ ] ford cobra logo
and instead of cobra i just put put put
pliskin in there
you know that's a good idea yeah
basically well i just found like a jpeg
or a png file the ford cobra logo and i
uh
auto traced it in illustrator yeah and
we and tweaked it so it was vector so
you can make it bigger yeah we make
these shirts and we almost make them use
them
we sell them but they're almost kind of
like our work shirts i wear them all the
time i got a [ __ ] [ __ ] ton of them
and i went to ups to go return that damn
router
in one of these a couple of days back
and [ __ ] uh the dude working with
this man that shirt is awesome man that
[ __ ] where the [ __ ] where'd you get that
and i said me and my girlfriend made
that he said oh man this is this you
want what no i don't want to buy one
yeah you know what that is right i'll
tell you he says yeah that's the four
cobra logo with pliskin on it yeah
see his only custom you're gonna do that
custom man bootleg yeah okay yeah well
if you come by again maybe i'll get
something like that bring one you know
yeah
well you know let's like i said i have a
lot of ideas for shirts it's just i
don't have a lot of time to do them
that's the only thing
i mean doing ones like that is fairly
easy because like i said we're just
ripping off somebody else's stuff and or
mixed mash in two things smashing two
things together that's always much
easier than doing that kind of stuff but
you know i'll tell you what the um
that tyrell industries [ __ ]
replicant more human than him and sure
[ __ ] a lot of people like that one
that one came out nice it's a lot and
where i wear that one to the club every
now and then people [ __ ] it looks
great with it with an industrial type
outfit it looks really good
yeah yeah i like the the logo is right
just the right size and it's round it's
got the japanese characters on it and
everything nobody really knows what it
is
kind of cool
i think what i did was um
the japanese on the outside
this is like i can't i think i just did
it in google translate so i'm sure like
the japanese says something yeah you're
probably wrong it's totally weird
because you know how google translate is
it's okay but you know tammy showed up
what's up tammy
greenspark says jenny you look fantastic
thank you this was one of the only uh
costumes i could come up with like
immediately i was like hey i have a
dress that looks like wednesday adams
and i have hair that i can braid i was
thinking about doing the wig but i
thought it would take too long to like
braid the wig one juan uh this says
jenny what movie is your costume from oh
you stop it man
krampus in here i don't look that
different from usual
um question our gramphthur says are you
handing out treats to your new neighbors
on sunday we'll see if people come uh
trick-or-treating yeah
i know there's kids in the neighborhood
because i can hear them yeah we can we
don't have any
i haven't done any pumpkins
i'm so
disappointed with myself oh i was i've
just been so busy i was calling and
dealing with the va and stuff i don't
had time to tell jenny
when we were look going through the uh
going through the broker to buy this
house
um
something came up on my credit and an
unpaid bill and
we tracked it down me and the va it was
for that hospital
and here's well that's what we figured
here's the thing it was one of the
doctors right
they never billed me to begin with
they never built they never submitted
the paperwork or the billing or anything
so they're probably going to drop it
i kind of hope that if i ever have to go
to the hospital for anything they'll
just like lose my [ __ ] yeah it was too
long it was too long ago and the va that
was a while back yeah the va is like no
we'll pay it and but the thing is is
that the doctor the doctor that
submitted it doesn't have the bill
anymore so so long ago i don't have the
bill yeah because when the [ __ ] was that
that was like 2016. was it or 14.
oh
six years ago
oh okay so 2015. yeah yeah it was like
yeah that was a long time ago yeah
so he didn't have the bill for it
well yeah after a certain amount of time
they just like destroy the [ __ ] or yeah
you know
damn
so um if he doesn't have the bill then
uh then it might as well not exist yeah
well then you know it's like in the v
the va was like well if you don't have
the bill then [ __ ] you can't prove
that you owe the money is we'll pay it
if you can come up with a bill
so it looks like that shit's gonna get
thrown out
oh oh thank you aaron go get some candy
for those kids they will we will i
promise very much we're not that lame
it's a 20 super chatter i appreciate it
you know what's crazy
out of the night people you know what's
crazy though we were talking about this
yesterday because tom was out there
trying to we have these two out the two
outside lights like on either side of
the garage okay so whoever lived here
before
um
all of the bulbs in there are broken in
the sockets right you can unscrew them
and so you can't get the bulbs out
and
we cannot figure out how to get
like okay so even if they weren't broken
we can't figure out how to get the [ __ ]
out of the lanterns so you can change
the bulbs
you can't take it apart or sit there and
look at it forever yeah we're like
sitting there looking at going well
like it's all right though that shit's
dated i'm gonna i'm gonna get rid of
those and putting new ones just i saw
how they're mounted i'll just buy new
ones
that's what i'm saying it's probably
just easier it's already wired and they
don't look that good they don't really
match the house i just want some i was
looking at what they had they had some
modern classic big square ones
yeah that was a square and they would
look a lot better with black let's get
it home and i'll put it see this house
has never had a real owner it just had
renters in it
and the last renters were in here for
over a year and a half evidently didn't
pay the rent because oh really i didn't
know that and when they left when they
as i was talking to the guy uh who has
the guy the guy who does the lawn here
we have a contract with we inherited the
contract for the groundskeeper yeah
and i was talking to him about it
and uh
he came here one day and our landlords
were out here and they had removed
everything from this house and it was
out in the front yard when they whoever
was here left and left it furnished
and they had to drill through the front
door to get in
wow
yeah they had to drill through the lock
on the front door and replace it and
everything and they left the place fully
furnished they just vanished
because they owed so much money
they just scattered
why they wanted us in here because we
were their best renters
well yeah i mean we lived in their other
property for 10 years and always paid
the rent on time and for 10 [ __ ]
years and who lived in here was like a
very large extended family according to
the neighbors
jenny went who lived in here and the
woman that jamaican woman says a lot of
people lived in there yeah well i was
talking to her her name is beverly by
the way um she came over here one day
when i was painting um because some
packages of ours that got delivered to
her house and she was like super nice
and she was like oh how many of you guys
are here and stuff and so i was like
telling her she's like oh that's good
because she's like before it's like so
many she was like so many cars and
honestly if you um there's a picture of
this house
on it's on google maps or google or
whatever the [ __ ] and there's like six
or seven cars in the driveway yeah so i
think that boarding house it was like an
extended uh family that lived here it
was like a bunch of which like i said
it's a big house so yeah i got i've
gotten mail here in the the and there's
been three or four different last names
on that on all the mail
so i think they were subletting it and
[ __ ] just letting random people live
here but what's weird um this house has
never had like a real owner
so none of the light fixtures make any
sense
a lot of stuff
was kind of left undone like only some
of the rooms seem like they've ever had
curtain rods installed in them there was
never
any internet installed in this house and
this
came with internet but they never asked
for it
yeah because i mean they had the hughes
net yeah dish right so i assume somebody
had that at some point although that
looked really old yeah but nobody had
like the free like the hoa internet
which we have now that's what we're
talking to you on it's high-speed
internet yeah and it's like and so i
don't know why they didn't do that they
do a cable hoa is 90 bucks a month and
it comes with [ __ ] high-speed
internet so
that's cheaper than most internet
services so
i don't understand what what what was
good you know i don't know what the hell
is going on in here and they never
really decorated it or painted it
correctly the landscaping's all [ __ ]
up
i mean but the thing is is that i don't
want to change anything until after i
purchase it because i don't want to
increase property value
but there's stacks of [ __ ] bricks out
on the side here that was used i mean
the yard actually looks pretty good i
mean the landscaping around the front
like and sides looks okay
but the ugly two-story house is just a
square box
the other ones are we
other houses are a lot nicer in here
if when we get it it's ugly it's just
plain it's very very plain it's just
clean especially compared to the other
ones but when i own it i'll fix it up
we'll put some accents on there make it
kind of like neo spanish or something
yeah because that's what a lot of the
other
neighborhoods it looks baroque and kind
of nouveau spaniard kind of looking
there are other houses that look just
like this one in this neighborhood
because like i said it's it's just like
any of these big like extended
neighborhoods they build it's always
they always have like four or five
different floor plans and usually when
you buy a lot you can like pick which
floor plan you want so we did drive
around the neighborhood and i was like
oh hey there's a house that looks like
ours and oh hey there's another one and
it's like you can see
uh you know some all the same kind of
floor plans but
like i said i don't think this house i
don't think the outside of it is ugly
it's just kind of like not as snazzy as
some of the other ones because it's more
box like and not it doesn't have like
kind of all the interesting
architectural
protuberances i guess it's just kind of
like
it's not exact it's just like kind of
like a tall box pretty much but you know
like i said it doesn't look that bad
it's just because there's no adornment
on it yeah there's no trim work or
adornment it's very simple
oh the other ones look a lot better they
kind of baroque style style to them and
spanish looking
stuff and extra all that could be added
to this house i mean yeah most of that
is just like aftermarket yeah or
i think some of it i think some of the
people that this is i think this is a
house i think that was just kind of put
together by real estate developers
just to get just to get a house in here
some of those other ones that are really
nice i think they were ordered that way
from the by the original owners just
well yeah because like i said yeah a lot
of the stuff they do if you have like a
home building company yeah they give you
a catalog they're like we're building
this new thing you buy a lot and then
it's like okay what kind of house do you
want here's all the extras that you
could have you know and here's what
colors it can be and here's what
fixtures and blah blah blah we can add
balconies this one doesn't have all the
nice [ __ ] like the balconies and the
little [ __ ] trim pieces and the
little [ __ ]
little round windows
little fancy [ __ ] doesn't have any of
that
which it would look a lot better if it
did
because
we're
we're still in one of the middle ranking
houses in here some of the single-story
ones are very simple they're kind of one
we moved out of
but um man compared to these mick
mansions they got big plots of land
compared to these yeah
some of these houses are really nice in
here
and i mean honestly this house
is every time i walk around it now like
i said it's still weird because we
haven't really lived here that long so
it doesn't it still feels like
not like my house not like somebody
else's house it's still like like i'm
staying at somebody else's house i that
will go away well we didn't paint all of
it ourselves and we haven't that you
know what i mean some of the some of the
colors of some of the rooms are like uh
kind of mint color and i was like yeah
yeah it's like a weird pale like make a
[ __ ] decision it's either a color or
it isn't
see i'm not down see i don't really like
i mean i know that when they rent stuff
out or they everybody like wants to
paint it neutral colors because they
assume that when you move into it you're
gonna paint it whatever color you want
yeah so they're trying to like make
something that's like not so offensive
yeah yeah so but honestly i i've never
liked i don't like white walls i don't
like beige i don't like anything like
that
i don't like any light i don't like blue
i don't like pale colors no at all
no be a color
let's see that's what i'm saying i'm
just like it just seems so wishy-washy
yeah it's like they don't want to commit
yeah and like yes i understand that like
dark colors because i was kind of like i
picked this color in here which is
essentially black it's like it's a dark
charcoal actually but i was just kind of
like [ __ ] it i mean i know that this is
hard to paint over like if somebody and
i think that our old house we had
painted our bedroom like a really deep
like a blood red yeah
it looked awesome i think they were a
little bit mad about that because red
they liked it when they saw it but then
later when they knew they had to paint
over it they're like oh it is hard to
paint over red i know but um because
i've had to do it before and it's a pain
you have to put like a lot of primer
over it
but
honestly i just can't i can't with white
walls i can't with white walls i can't
with beige walls i can't stand it it
just looks unfinished
it looks style too blah it's out of it
looks like you didn't make a decision
about anything
it looks like a rental property yeah
that's exactly what it looks like so it
looks like you can never i can never
like settle into a place that just has
like beige walls i'll paint the [ __ ] out
of this house [ __ ] i'm gonna buy in
three months i'm gonna faint the [ __ ]
out of this house
that big that big living room out there
is gonna have an arcade in it with
[ __ ] stand-up art video arcade games
in it the little miniature ones put that
in there i know i'm excited to have a
bar in there i already got a nice
[ __ ] color lights and [ __ ] it's got
big picture windows look how overlooked
the neighborhood looks good
uh juan says what am i drinking that is
it's peach vodka right yeah it tastes
like peach vodka and orange juice and
it's got some whipped cream vodka in
there too oh does it okay it's just i
could tell it was peach because i could
alright so today is open lines if you
guys have any questions on any kind of
cases or anything we did in the back or
if you want uh anything we've done in
our back catalog or if you have any
questions about common events go you go
ahead and throw it down into the dab
comment section and we can start the con
we can start the conversation off with
anything that you guys want to talk
about um everybody's drinking it's early
it's on a saturday it's friday it's a
few minutes on friday
the only reason why you guys are here is
because you're not going anywhere uh so
it might as well we're not going
anywhere we're not going anywhere either
next month's gonna be rough man because
i gotta [ __ ] watch that damn credit
card [ __ ] for three months
well yeah because you gotta watch your
credit card and honestly like
to get this low i mean yeah well and i
you know and i had to spend a lot of
money when we moved because like i said
i needed my furniture new furniture for
the office because i trashed like the
old furniture from the old one so
i'm not broke but i'm kind of broke
i'm broke adjacent
after i get everything paid all i'll
have all i'll have is somewhere between
three or four hundred dollars to live
off of next month
but we don't really i mean
honestly you know we have
uh the amc stubs thing so it's like if
we're really desperate we can go see a
movie for free we have to pay gas though
you have to pay gas and it's far i get
that uh you know that's that's another
thing that's kind of sucky i got it we
got enough [ __ ]
groceries to last us a long time i'm not
really worried about food it's just
we're going to be [ __ ] housebound
basically yeah so that kind of sucks
because i don't think i can go out for
halloween which blocks yeah we're going
to have to cut clubbing down to maybe
once a month maybe twice a month
depending on how much we spend when we
get there if we pre-game or we go to
tom's tom might be able to take care of
us
tom knows what i'm doing that's true say
tom man i gotta [ __ ] i gotta pay for
this house brother [ __ ] tabs on you
okay
oh okay yeah yeah okay yeah zombie all
right he could give me some free tabs
i've done enough posters for those times
seriously
yeah greenspark says i do that at my job
design houses and neighborhoods for
builders yeah it's so much better to buy
your own land my company takes people
for a ride yeah i kind of feel like well
one of the things about this house
that makes it attractive is this the
plot of land that it's on
it's big it is very big it's got a huge
yard
so theoretically if the [ __ ] value
gets high enough you could tear this
house down and [ __ ] put another man
you could put a mansion here yeah
there's nothing actually happened
honestly there's plenty of room to put a
pool in the back too yeah i don't want
to poop
you don't [ __ ] no too much money i
wouldn't mind having one yeah you build
the [ __ ] and you never see it you
never stay you never go you never use it
i would use it yeah i would like having
a pool the only reason i didn't use the
one at the old neighborhood that much
was because it was the whole
neighborhoods pool and there was always
some [ __ ] in it not when i went
it was about just be by myself you know
i liked it
so i always go in there during the
weekdays during the day
yeah that was the only time you could go
because if you went on the weekends like
weekend mornings
like nine o'clock in the morning yeah
when everyone was at work or school you
know you could go in there uh tammy says
we're trying to fix up my husband's
grandmother's three bedroom cottage
style house everything is outdated she
died nine years ago and his mom finally
decided she's gonna give it to him i
mean
it's just kind of like i don't know
there's so much this house is like so
big and there's so much that i want to
do with it but
i don't have enough money to do all of
it well you have to take out a loan
against it yeah to get it done i mean
especially i'm excited about that big
living room area the upstairs living
room area i just like i want to make
that like the the party room i just i
just want to get this [ __ ] deal
[ __ ] settled
once the deal settled i'll feel better
because that'll take 90 days
to get it all done and by then i'll know
what electricity costs in this
[ __ ] yeah because we still don't
still don't really know and i still
don't know what water cost i still
haven't figured out how to turn the
outside water on yet it's two separate
water supplies one of them's drinking
water the other one is [ __ ]
city water that [ __ ] waters that that
huge ass lawn
and that
that computer that controls all the
[ __ ] sprinkler banks it won't come
off it's got power and everything but
which tells me that somebody cut off the
water main to that sprinkler
i can't find it i've been all over this
house
it's gonna be a whole paranormal [ __ ]
it's like a paranormal episode of this
house but where's the [ __ ] water
mains i can't find them
can't find them but ghosts know where
the water mains are
what you doing pokey i still kind of
wonder about those about the outside
lights though because
who broke off all of those bulbs uh they
were trying to reach up in there and try
to unscrew them and all of them are
broken yeah it's because they don't
unscrew they were kind of
were kind of like shaped like a candle
yeah they had a candle flat frame and uh
it had like an outer sleeve that slipped
over them i think it that i think
by looking at it
the little bulb you pushed it straight
up oh you know i mean it plugged in it
didn't screw in they
they would plug straight in and they
twisted them and broke them because
they're they were like retro hand blown
glass and i think they had
elements in there that wavered like it
was flickering
candle yeah like we used to have
something like that that's all retro
[ __ ] you know i mean you can get led
stuff that does that now i'm going to
get rid of those
that's they don't fit this house anyway
this house is modern and that those
lantern looking things were [ __ ]
spanish
and it didn't mix i'm gonna put modern
ones out there the house looks like a
[ __ ] modern box so everything in it's
gonna it's weird though like not having
outside lights yeah i mean what we've
been doing is that you know in the front
there's like you know the high ceiling
and there's a light
you know inside that's
you know right by where the front door
is so it's like we usually just leave
that light on so we can see what we're
doing
i'm going to dig up some people i knew
from back in the horse days there's a
guy that i know that does owns a
landscaping company once everything's
all sealed i'm going to bring him down
here and seal them bricks right there do
something creative
yeah
yeah because somebody there was
something out there
in the ground like pathways or something
made out of bricks
stones like cobblestones and now they're
just stacked up in a huge cube next to
the house
the inside the bushes
there's a lot of them underneath those
there's something there one day when we
have some money yeah it would be nice to
get the driveway redone
yeah because the driveway kind of looks
what i would do is something crazy and
the driveway is long it's real long and
it's got [ __ ] oil stains on it what i
would do is take some kind of a [ __ ]
paint lay some kind of a [ __ ]
high-tech paint and paint that
painted [ __ ]
you know a tarmac color or maybe like a
[ __ ] brown or a red something like
that like a reddish brown
yeah yeah
because it's it's just a slab [ __ ]
concrete papers would be nice too but
then break it up that's expensive could
bust it all up and replace it with
stones
i think that would look nice yeah
honestly i think the like pavers and
stuff like that look way classier than
just yeah maybe i'll bring somebody in
just leave the concrete slab and then
have somebody pave it with stones over
it
yeah that might look nice yeah man and
it make it look like cobblestone or
something because it is a long ass
driveway like when we first got to the
house i'm like holy [ __ ] crap
it's just you know it's not like
but it's like long for a certain thing
to do with this house is buy it
stay in it for about five to ten years
get some equity and then sell it
maybe so i don't know we'll see we'll
see
the property values around here will go
up
they probably will because they're
building
stuff all around here yeah this area has
grown a lot not as much as where we did
live but that where we did live like i
said used to be kind of like
suburban like right on the edge of rural
and then now it's kind of like might as
well be downtown for christ's sake yeah
um all the [ __ ] they built around it and
all this they built new houses and stuff
and this place is still rural but
they're building new [ __ ] here all
they're building new houses in this
neighborhood yeah
so they're building new neighborhoods
like around yeah
well there's a lot of room there's a lot
of land out here they're they're
completing that free we freeway to
connect this to [ __ ] tampa and
orlando once that's just done this place
is gonna blow up yeah that's only i
think the first two legs of it are done
we took
the door is already worth money yeah
mountain and we're not that far from
mountain yeah
um grampar says is it close to the
villages that place is growing like a
bad fungus not that far not that far
we're i think we're probably closest the
main city that we're close to is like
mount dora mound
says we're dora
stanford yeah zach says would you have a
room that's completely painted black
though yeah i don't know we've got one
right here yeah this is like i mean i
left the trim white yeah just because
painting trim is kind of a pain i might
paint the trim black at some point
[Laughter]
you know what i mean but i thought it'd
be like a nice contrast i don't know
i'll think about it
or maybe gray that would look kind of
nice too i don't like i said i don't
like white i don't like white anything
yeah i like white i don't like beige i
don't like these [ __ ] wishy-washy
colors man like you said be a color be a
color yeah the my old house that i used
to own in daytona
i painted it
my inspiration for the whole house was
suspiria so i painted like pretty much
every room like a different color like
the the living room was like blood red
the bedroom was like dark blue
um i had a room that was
like dark green the kitchen was hot pink
and silver
and i had a room that was like part like
dark purple
and all of the doors and the hallways
were all black and then all the doors i
had them painted if you see in suspiria
there's like this kind of like art
nouveau
type of uh situation going on on the
doors and i painted them like that i
couldn't afford to do like glass insets
like in the movie but i painted them to
look like that yeah graham there's lakes
all over this place and swamps
you've got a you gotta cross a river
that looks like the amazon river on your
way here
there's a bridge it goes over it goes
over it
um
badass domain says i look like wednesday
adams well that's good because that's
the costume like i said i'm i'm the old
geeky wednesday adams
filthy gardener says thompson starter
only fans okay uh um um
filthy guard yeah shake that you tell me
why i need to start at only fans and
then maybe i'll consider it shake that
tight little booty yeah
for moolah yeah can you do that anymore
six packs coming in man
y'all [ __ ] better watch out because
i'm gonna be putting all i can i already
posted some photographs on
on [ __ ] um yeah
me and my sexual policemen outfit yeah
sexually i'd pull up lights [ __ ]
flash and whoo
jump out
like something out of [ __ ] you're
like jump out of a cage ymca i gotta
jump out of a cake or something yeah
yeah no no sure or anything make
the sex police making sure all you
[ __ ] are having sex that's sex okay
good you have you're not having sex
write a citation you need a whistle yeah
yeah
that's what you should call your only
fan's channel the sex police sex
policeman thomas ross sex police sexual
policemen
can i make you a business card that says
yeah yeah
sexual law enforcement
when you when you want to be like
fancy
uh zach says how about rooms that are
painted cheerful colors uh
i'm not a fan uh i'd love to have an all
yellow room in a house let me okay
my mom
that arcade's going to be cheerful but
it's going to be cool too
what will when you say cheerful what do
you mean it's just going to look like a
modern and [ __ ] you know what i mean
kind of like
bright and a good place like you'd have
a drake or [ __ ] play some games or do
something you know what i mean
like what color were you thinking i
don't know maybe bright green or
something or well now i will say or blue
oh thank you mango tonight's episode of
13 o'clock is sponsored by silver
shamrock silver shamrock
thank you very much mango badges 20
pounds 20 pounds nice
what i did though i mean this room is
essentially black with white trim what i
did in the bathroom that's adjoining
though i always wanted to do like an art
nouveau
uh kind of absinthy type of thing so
actually the bathroom in there is like
green it's like a what would you call
that green absolutely it's like an
absinthe green chartreuse
yeah i guess i'm just like i was going
to think that
the living room would be like something
to compliment that yeah and actually i
really like that color so i've got like
a kind of like all like alphonse mooca
or musha or however you say his name i
got all his stuff in there i got a bunch
of absinthe uh kind of framed prints
that i've had and uh i got green towels
it's green and gray actually in there so
i have like green gray silver type of
situation going on yeah but uh yeah i do
like that so i don't know i'm
but like i said if you're gonna have a
color have a color i'm not a fan of
yellow i'm not a fan of but honestly i
can't really think of any other color
other than yellow that i wouldn't paint
a wall as long as it's a color
i don't really like this like little
pasta i don't like pastel anything
it has to be kind of like saturated yeah
you're not committing
that's exactly exactly you're trying to
be cutesy about it yeah it's like well i
want it blue but it's like not real blue
but it's not really blue it's just kind
of like this baby blue i'm like man [ __ ]
that if you look at the really nice
houses that are around today
[ __ ] you know what i mean
that you know that [ __ ] the same
freaking famous people or [ __ ] people
that have money what they own there's
colors in there yeah they go yeah we're
gonna make that [ __ ] red or it's gonna
be blue colors are awesome yeah it's
gonna it's gonna have or the walls are
gonna be dark brown and it that can be
done right too that'll look dark brown
and red so it looked really good in that
damn
spanish [ __ ] castle we were looking
at yeah see i don't even mind i don't
mind brown if you you know
yeah if you have the right [ __ ] going on
if it fits
brown would have looked real dark brown
walls it doesn't have to be all the
walls maybe just like one or two of the
walls
see the other ones could be another
color depending on what you're doing
they just have to be complementary
colors
i mean i'm a big fan obviously of like
you know really like baroque kind of
stuff for like uh you know that kind of
like damask or damascus or whatever like
wallpaper i like that kind of [ __ ] so i
like that old-fashioned kind of like you
know like all the old hammer horror
movies and with that creepy wallpaper
and i love that kind of stuff i don't
really like so anything that's like i
said like kind of a deep color
i like that i just don't i don't like
pastel colors jack says speaking of
colors what's the best looking movie
that you've seen dude there's so many of
them the best looking movie but yeah
there's so many of them i mean even some
of the john wick movies are [ __ ]
fantastic looking the color palettes are
[ __ ] great i mean suspiria is my
favorite there's still yeah i just love
the look of that i love the look of the
inside of the house like i said my old
house i designed the whole house kind of
around that
because i loved that aesthetic so much
like that color scheme and
the the kind of art nouveau insets on
the doors and stuff i love that [ __ ] so
much it's like and i still do yeah if i
could afford it i would do like a total
house like that i would say [ __ ]
recently in terms of action movies the
whole john wick series
and that last john wick was visually
real real good good color palette shot
really well um even they even had little
[ __ ] subtitles popping out of
people's mouths
those movies are much more than meets
the eye actually
the john wick movies yeah i mean the
yeah those are beautiful looking movies
almost like they're almost like cross
between film and
cartoon but they're good they're really
good
which to me that's what cinema is
yeah might as well give you something
nice to look at yeah
badass domain also brought up mandy
which was also a beautiful beautiful
movie
i'm really into i really really like all
those kind of super saturated colors and
i really love
that horror filmmakers nowadays inspired
by dario argento and like movies from
the 80s are really into that retro
let's have these like
saturated like red magenta lights
blue lights
green lights i love that look i just
really really like that i was seeing
some [ __ ] just okie doke [ __ ] some
of these millennials and [ __ ] [ __ ]
doing movie reviews and
i don't understand why the lights dude
man if you if you have to be explained
if if you have to explain to a
[ __ ] what art is and what
and what cinema is
stay the [ __ ] off the internet man don't
don't you're not allowed on the internet
says tom ross sexual policeman it says
tom ross
they're trying to damn they're trying to
[ __ ] critique
films okay
from other eras and they don't they
don't get it you know what i mean like i
saw some of these guys critiquing
one of the ones that they critiqued was
um
was conan the barbarian they didn't get
it remember when the witch
turned into a witch when they were
having sex
yeah well a blue light [ __ ] turns on
as part of the effects like during her
transformation they were mystified i
don't really why the blue light
what's the blue light for you know i
mean just i just because she's magic
[ __ ] dude
if you don't understand art you know
what i mean don't [ __ ] talk about
well it might just i don't think that's
a millennial problem i think that just
might be even like a fat guy a problem
well he was in there talking to his
buddy and [ __ ] because to be honest it's
like like i said and i've said this
before like when i whenever i review
movies and stuff i'm very willing to
like this is your movie this is your
vision
i'm willing to be like okay show me like
what do you want to show me i'm not
going to be like well why'd you do this
and why did you do that and why you know
what i mean if that's what they wanted
to do then [ __ ] it well i think uh some
young people because they're so used to
imagery happening all the time
they didn't know
they don't know that some of it's just
emotional
and if
if you're limited in the amount of
technology that you have you can't show
certain imagery so you have to
you have to kind of uh uh the [ __ ]
[ __ ] kind of
try to induce an emotion in the viewer
and if you have to change the lighting
in the middle of it that's supposed to
be that there's been like a change in
the room it's like theatrics you know
what i mean
but i guess some
people the way they grew up that
everything is very literal and very you
know what i mean
there's no excuse yeah and i mean and if
you want to do it's subtle
and and you know that's fine too but if
you just want to go whole hog with the
[ __ ] and be like yeah i'm gonna put all
these big [ __ ] colorful lights in
there then you can do that too it's
totally fine it's all good yeah well
that down everybody's got a different
like vision a different way of doing
things and it's fine well it works it's
still lights work yeah
i mean what was that what was the
[ __ ] one that had oh [ __ ] old
wes's name [ __ ] went in there it was
fighting the chuck e cheese monster
never said willie's wonderland willie's
wonderland yeah [ __ ] what was it what
was that actor's name again uh nicholas
kate nicholas cage
nicholas cage didn't say word willie's
wonderland and when willie's wonderline
happened a lot of the [ __ ] that was
happening during those
it was just done with lighting
colored lighting
in the backgrounds just to give you you
know
to give emotion and tone to it
if
to me it's obvious what it is
that lighting is just an artistic
description
it's a movie it's a visual it's visual
you know it's a visual medium if you
have to explain that to somebody then
[ __ ] well like i said this is why i kind
of feel like they're okay so
going back to suspiria again there's a
certain group of people that would be
like why did this woman is running
through this house and she suddenly
falls into a room that's completely
filled with barbed wire that doesn't
make any sense yeah there's those kind
of people and then there are people like
me that are just be like yeah yeah okay
that's what happened
it's dream logic yeah it's fine it's
just just roll with it it's visual it
looks cool yeah that's all you have to
worry about it's just it's
artistic expression yeah it just looks
cool so don't worry about it i don't
know what it is it doesn't have to make
sense yeah
and in the case that i was talking about
millennials i guess
certain millennials
don't understand our artistic expression
the same way we understand it i guess
they're too set in
realism i guess realism and computer
imagery
although that's i don't know if that's
the case though because i do kind of
feel like a lot of movies that came out
nowadays are kind of like hearkening
back to i know that yeah like back in
those days when it seems like people
people appreciate it yeah which like
that's awesome
because like i said i can't
i guess some people can't like i said i
don't know if that's a generational
thing or if that's just like a person
that's just too literal and can't just
[ __ ] i remember like guys my dad's
generation seeing those horror movies
and movies that were doing that and they
got it 100 and those dudes were [ __ ]
numb skulls but they got they knew what
art was
you know i mean they knew what artistic
expression was they they understood what
film was that film didn't wasn't real
it was just like back in the old days
when like pablo picasso started doing
the cubish [ __ ] and everybody's like
that's not what a lady looks like and
yeah
right yeah
yeah
right i'm trying to do something here
well even rednecks in mississippi
[ __ ] growing up
that grew up as [ __ ] teenagers in the
70s would see [ __ ] like you said dario
gentle stuff and then you go yeah yeah
you see that hell yeah hell yeah
stabbed it right in the eye you know
they didn't sit there and try to analyze
why was there a blue light on her
yeah it's like that one that lights
wouldn't happen like yeah yeah why is
there like why is there a room in this
castle that's completely filled with
barbed wire yeah yeah yeah
yeah
why is she like stabbing in her heart
and like the heart's still beating that
doesn't make any sense at all i'm like
yeah no
yeah she failed and the barbed writer
got that [ __ ] with [ __ ] was badass
same thing happened to me
i was hunting hogs i fell right down
there and then briar patched me up just
like that it's just like that yeah i
remember when that happened
you know that's i mean it's like like i
said that movie in particular it's a
fairy tale all right i mean it's fairy
tale it's about witches so calm down but
yeah so
so don't don't try to like make it
that wouldn't happen
uh jay bird said go for odd stripes and
gloss and matte in any color yeah see i
like not only do i like color i also
like texture
so i kind of like i've seen these really
cool rooms that were done with like
stripes of like color and wallpaper or
like you said like colors that were like
matte and gloss and it looks like really
cool because it's kind of like texture
but it's like really subtle
um zach said i loved how colorful the
new bond movie was
yeah and probably uh yeah and carrie by
brian de palma is maybe my favorite
director
yeah that's uh yeah that was a great
that especially that last scene at the
prom and everything like that danny
rowling says uh logan's run and og willy
wonka had good trippy colors yeah
i love i love the willy wonka but look i
have that uh cell over there i think no
need for me she sent me that yeah i had
one of the original cells from the willy
wonka movie yeah zach i was thinking
about the new um
bond movie again
we were lucky to get five good movies in
her in a row out of out of craig craig
was a good bond that was a good run
that was a good run for james bond i was
and that last movie was much better than
i thought it was going to be i've been
hearing [ __ ] [ __ ] you know i mean
just the stuff they were putting out in
the in in the in the press i was like oh
man that movie's gonna [ __ ] suck
well yeah you said that repeatedly i'm
like can we just watch it
and then we'll see what happens see this
is why i don't ever want to he was like
before we went and saw dune like a day
or two before he's like oh these guys
are like talking about dude i'm like
yeah yeah
just let me see it i don't want to like
listen to anybody i know but i don't
want to listen to anybody else's opinion
about it or like i don't want to know
anything about it i just want to go see
it yeah they were well i was i was
hearing good things
and you know what and [ __ ] when bond
came out i was still kind of hearing
mixed stuff
from it it's like yes it's not as bad as
we thought it was going to be it's
pretty good but you know there's
controversy on this and that but you
know i grew up watching james bond
and uh that last movie was a big
send-off for daniel craig it
it gave it gave [ __ ] a shout out to
all the other bonds of the past
all the other cues from the past
or but without being like overly like
cutesy about it yeah it wasn't cute it's
just that it and it wrapped up
everything it even wrapped up felix's
story i [ __ ] i love what they did
with felix
uh where james bond at the end says yeah
i had a brother once his name was felix
remember that [ __ ] yeah and all that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
uh
and and then bond actually working for
the cia for a bit that was pretty cool
um
and then
the [ __ ]
it went retro bond for a bit at the
[ __ ] at the spectre party with the
eye they're walking the eye around and
you could hear a [ __ ] that was some
[ __ ] freaky ass [ __ ] man
walking the eye around and you hear
[ __ ]
what was his name um
uh what was the bad guy's name blowfield
blowfield yeah you hear blofeld's voice
talking you are all my children and all
those kind of weird [ __ ] it's just
[ __ ] damn this is some weird [ __ ]
and that was kind of like
it's from some of the old [ __ ] bodies
yeah that was like old school but like
old school bond because i feel like the
newer ones were more like grounded in
realism like the old ones had some like
weird like fans yeah but it was still
kind of realistic it's just that it went
surreal yeah like they were in there
[ __ ] gotham nothing wrong with that
they were in their [ __ ] gothic fetish
[ __ ]
spectre party you know that
[ __ ] are getting getting weird
at the spectre party
and then uh
yeah some blowfield got double crossed
by one of his dudes and the [ __ ]
the virus and everything you know that
was pretty cool i liked it they were
gonna kill bond in front of everybody
else part of the celebration but didn't
go down that way
um
and then they bring back then they bring
that one girl in
and she does that [ __ ] corny super
girl out
you know she's supposedly first day on
the job and she killed all these other
dudes and bonds like oh yeah yeah you
just started first day out of the job
yeah dude yeah can i just say yeah you
know honestly it's good honor to armist
yeah i love her yeah she's cute man
she's adorable as [ __ ] everything i've
seen her she was great and she was in
knives out yeah she's been a like
lobster stupid lots of stuff yeah she
was in the blade runner she yeah she's
awesome
uh so i she she kind of like i don't
want to say she stole the movie like the
new blonde movie but
she wasn't in it long enough i mean she
wasn't in long enough to steal it but
like when she was in it i was like that
i think that might have been my favorite
part yeah that character was uh an
homage to all the other bombed girl
characters and they just that was to
give
daniel craig and and that james bond
send off
you know and an homage to all the other
bomb girls who show up and do some
[ __ ] fantastic [ __ ]
and then and then they're gone you know
i thought that was cool
yeah and like i said i like her yeah if
you're saying about shane movies you'll
understand it it wanted to go classic
bond in a couple of in a couple of
scenes classic bond like roger moore
cheesy
i don't want to call it it wasn't
overtly
it was counter plausible
it's just it's just homage in some of
the old james bond i mean to be fair a
lot of the stuff that happened even in
the daniel craig james bond movies were
not wouldn't have been really plausible
yeah right yeah um you know obviously he
would have been killed like a million
times over like some of the [ __ ] that he
did in there but it's you know it's fine
like i said i'm not gonna like worry too
much about it well if you know anything
about the intelligence work
that whole business is about not being
noticed
so being a super fit
good looking white dude who drives
sports cars around expensive sports cars
and he's fantastic and he makes a
spectacle of himself goes to all these
rich people and everybody knows his name
yeah and everybody knows that is not the
way it is well obviously [ __ ]
you offer like i said it's not it's not
a real believable story to start with so
it's just like just let it just let it
rise right the most believable spy in
the whole [ __ ] series would have been
felix
that was close that's closer to
intelligence type guys just kind of a
non-descript kind of low speaking tone
dude who's not really he would if he was
he wouldn't stand up yeah if you saw him
in a crowd he wouldn't stand out yeah
and then you're assuming that he's a
male a lot of them are
but the best buys have always will
always be and have always been females
because
it's their their well a crude term would
be a sex operative
okay
it's a girl who works for an agency
to get information on a certain
company or government agency or whatever
she meets the dude they start sleeping
together she moves in with him it's a
girlfriend and for years and turns out
she's telling everything she knows
dudes once they sleep with some woman
they tend to just tell them everything
because they trust them now because
they're sleeping with them yeah and
that's the best way to collect
intelligence on somebody that's right
and that goes all the way back
to like the 1500s the 1600s the romans
knew that
all right the romans did that kind of
[ __ ]
um well and even still nowadays i kind
of feel like people don't
don't expect
women to be spies spies you're right no
even now yeah but that's the main ones
and that was always the main ones but
like i said that's why they're the best
ones because nobody expects them you're
not thinking that way yeah and then uh
some of them might be old women too but
they're just you know depending on what
they're doing you know what i mean i
want to be a spy yeah surprise
they're not fighters they're talkers and
listeners
that's basically what they're well like
i said all their so they're trying to
get info yeah so basically it's always
better to get info
in a way like you said where you're kind
of ingratiating yourself into
a scene where people just like talking
to you because it's like
yeah they think that you're their buddy
or their girlfriend or something like
that yeah and like you can get all kind
of like fascinating information yes
um
damon says hello this is a question for
tom and jenny what is the weirdest
conspiracy theory you have heard of
wow that's a long list
um weirdest conspiracy theory
honestly one of i don't know if this is
that weird but the whole like faked the
moon landing thing that's pretty weird
yeah and it didn't happen um they didn't
fake it well no i know
but some people actually do think they
did yeah it was easier to believe that
they faked it i think for some people
but they didn't fake it they made a
movie about that called capricorn one
i always kind of like i don't know i've
never seen it but i heard about it i saw
it a long time ago i remember it being
good i don't remember a lot about it
though
but i kind of feel like the best
conspiracy theories like the weirdest
ones are from like a long time ago like
the hollow earth kind of [ __ ] yeah like
that kind of [ __ ] yeah that was one of
the conspiracy theory though that was
not science fiction
yeah i guess so
although i guess some people actually
did believe it so
yeah it was german
um yeah i'm trying to think of like
another the weirdest comparison
most of these conspiracy theories what
the lizard people won where everybody's
lizard people
that's pretty weird
yeah if that's what he meant
david ike or yeah
i'm not really much into him i haven't
heard everything that he has said over
the years he's a loon
who knows dudes trying to make money
yeah i was gonna i said either he's a
loon or he's like um you know a weirdo
for dollars or
it could be that he's trying to talk
about organized crime
but he has to cloud what he's talking
about
in yeah
a veil of [ __ ] insanity so it has
plausible deniability
so they won't come after him and kill
him
they're not real humans they're lizard
people because they're cold-hearted and
they're filled with venom
is he is this an allegory
you know what i mean i'm being actually
[ __ ] yeah that actually goes back to
the roman period also
if you spoke out against the [ __ ]
imperial family all right you would die
they'll kill you okay couldn't speak out
against you really couldn't speak out
too much against the roman imperial gods
you could get killed too but you could
speak out against them in allegory
because it was deniable
and that's really what uh the book of
revelation was about it was a lot of
allegory
about rome greece uh the the parth uh
the what was it the parth the parthen uh
the pathogenian army uh there's a bunch
of [ __ ] that they were talking about
that time
so some of some of the mystic
some of this mystic stuff that ended up
in religions was actually kind of like
double speak
alex jones style double speak where it's
mostly talking about politics but they
can't come out and say it there wasn't
freedom of speech back then
so you had clouded in allegory
symbolism
um so was it a lie no it wasn't a lie it
was just my it was just probably
incorrect
you know especially
in the book of revelation it's not a lie
it's just incorrect
and even the eastern roman empire the re
the eastern orthodox church
they don't have that in their new
testament revelations because they said
it was a false prophecy
rome jesus did not come back and destroy
rome
rome converted to christianity
so therefore rome could have not have
been the [ __ ] of babylon
rome could not have been
a a
creation of the antichrist because rome
converted to christianity and brought
christianity to the world so it all has
to do with the way you're looking at it
you know but during the time of the
writing of the book of revelations
whoever wrote that
was damning rome
they're not even really sure when that
was written there's no date on it
sometime after the fall of
the temple in
jerusalem sometime during the time of
nero
because he's mentioned
the thing about um
thing about wormwood being cast into the
sea and destroying all
certain amount of fish in the boats
they're probably talking about mount
vesuvius
so
but there's no date it wasn't a lie it
was just wrong see i mean [ __ ] like that
interests me though because i'm always
kind of interested in these
like i said all these biblical stories
mythological stories because a lot of
them are actually
um it's interesting to see where they
got the ideas from like i said i can't
remember the name of that series that we
saw on youtube like years ago but it was
that one where it was pointing out how
a lot of the biblical stories were based
on astrology essentially yeah and it was
like and the way that it lined up was
like mind-blowing yeah
what happened is a lot of the old gods
um from kind of like the canaanite era
got demoted into being kings or
um legendary people from the bible like
esau
you know the description of esau
is the sun
and the description is certain
there's actually and sometimes i i gotta
[ __ ] dig it that's been a long time
since i've read about
every one of those old testament
patriarchs there's a certain number of
them and it lines up with a certain
amount of [ __ ] like the 12 signs of
the zodiac and each one of them fits the
description of the zodiac signs yeah
it's like disturbingly yeah so
what they've done is they've taken their
old sciences and their old religions and
cult and recodified them and turned made
and demoted them from gods into
legendary patriarchs of the past
so i guess
so they're not erasing their old
histories they're they're not erasing
their old religion they're re-explaining
it
yeah they're saying these gods that your
ancestors believed in they weren't wrong
or they weren't false gods it's just
that our understanding of them was wrong
this is what they really were
that's what they're doing yeah
and like i said that kind of [ __ ]
fascinates me all that kind of like how
religions form like mythologies form all
that kind of stuff is like really really
same thing with like marvel comics and
dc comics and star wars and everything
everything
all these stories belong in genres
and as they continue they get rebooted
and recondensed and then reinterpreted
and then there's the extended universe
and then there's [ __ ] that's that's no
longer canon we're not getting we're not
gonna we're not gonna have [ __ ] it's
absolutely no different it's exactly the
same thing then comic book lore and it's
i think people might think that's very
funny right but it's not it's exactly
the same
it's exactly the same because that's how
that's how people's brains work that's
how we tell stories
yeah um so i don't so it's not
denigrating religion or comic books
uh you know saying that those two things
are exactly the same they are exactly
the same that's how we tell stories when
people go see these marvel movies you
know what i mean and they just [ __ ]
love all this marvel stuff it's the same
thing the ancients were doing with
religions yes exact same thing exact
same like i said there's no difference
at all they were paying to go to the
temple to see reenactments and [ __ ]
drink
uh weird alcohols that were mixed with
drugs and they'd [ __ ] dance and
[ __ ] sing move music and think about
things that ain't perhaps yeah and
[ __ ] talking about how badass
dionysus was
and then they're talking about oh yeah
if i can bring out bring out the seders
you know what i mean
and bring out yeah
yeah you know get it on people you know
it was like a club scene too
and you p that's where all the money was
you had to pay to get in and paying for
services and paying to get blessed and
paying to get forgiven for things that
you did or paying for wishes to be
fulfilled you know
prayers and [ __ ] and that's a huge
industry huge industry so
it hasn't changed no not at all and i i
know that people might think that's
weird but that's like
yeah it's it's the same exact thing
marvel extended universe is exactly the
same thing as a bible and i'm gonna
sealer i'm gonna say it right here yeah
same exact thing they all then
now here in the west we're almost
post-religion so we've gotten rid of a
lot of these old religions we're making
up new ones
if you actually go through like german
philosophies and
you know [ __ ] arthroscope and howard
and friedrich nietzsche and then you can
go to marx and all those other guys and
then you can even go into the [ __ ]
nazis like goebbels and [ __ ]
they'll tell you that
there was an evolution to thinking and
it went from
hero worship into legend
which went into religion
which went into um a
philosophy which evolved into politics
and that politics is a part of the
religious spectrum it's the newest form
of it
and all of those european style
socialist philosophies
international socialism national
socialism
liberal socialism whatever they are all
about making
politics the national religion
like
germany was the fatherland that was the
god you know what i mean then you had
the fuhrer who was the [ __ ] savior
they're all replacing
religious motif with
motifs of the state
and then the the uh the commies did the
exact same thing trying to make the
perfect soviet man
uh trying to bring equality and all this
boy they did some crazy ass ways of
bringing equality killing [ __ ] huge
swallows of your population starving
them to death all kinds of weird [ __ ]
they're all bad forms of government
government in itself is bad it just is
it's it's always going to be abused
which me i'm just kind of like a
neo-anarchist now i don't believe in the
powers of large states i think they're
all illegitimate and they're all the
ultimate form of religion and their
ultimate form of [ __ ]
organized crime really if you look at
them they're just organized crime they
just have assumed the mantle of [ __ ]
legitimacy but they're all crooks
i believe in the individual and the
individual's family and your individual
rights to say no
that's what i believe in
um
and uh we're going to let the chips fall
where they may we're going to see what
happens
but utopian ideology always fails always
filled with the nazis and filled with
the commies it's going to always fail
because humans are not ants this is not
an ant colony
humans were not made for this that's why
they want us dead mostly
all those regimes always wanted to kill
off people that didn't fit in
they would just call them different
things you know
dirty people that [ __ ] don't believe
what we believe we're going to have to
put them in camps
and they did that's what they do
that's what they do that's i don't trust
them don't trust any of them
if you give somebody authority he's
gonna [ __ ] abuse it
somebody said we should do a show about
jfk the jfk yeah yeah
maybe we should honestly i think when i
was younger i thought there was a big
conspiracy about it but the more i read
about it the less i think that that's
the case it happened too long ago it's
very suspicious it's suspicious i'm not
saying there's not suspicious aspects to
it i just don't know if that's
harvey oswald was connected with too
many people that would have had motive
especially the guys from the free cubit
movement he was working with them
and him
him
marrying a soviet woman and living in
the soviet union for a certain period of
time but then being allowed to come back
that's just got the [ __ ] the stink of
[ __ ] cia all over it
and i do think he was a patsy
and i saw the film
and i understand the 6.5 carcano rifle
it'd be real hard to [ __ ] work that
bolt action and make that many hits in
that amount of time
i think there was more than one guy
i'm just saying that
because that was a hard shot
and it was several hard hits on a moving
target from that distance
with that little short 6.5 car being
with [ __ ] iron sights
and you're talking about oswald oswald
yeah he was a qualified marine
marksman
those are still hard shots man
even if he worked alone i don't think he
was alone
corinthians says how pan became the
devil yeah that's kind of a big story
about how a lot of the pagan gods who
were not evil but he stretched the
imagination but once kind of
christianity took over
they sort of relegated yeah a lot of the
other gods to well pan and the demon
status pan and the seders would be easy
to repaint as evil under the christian
ethos because they were sexual they
drank a lot and they liked women and you
know that's the root of all evil from
the viewpoint of the [ __ ] christian
women women and dudes chasing women
drinking in those damn bars and trying
to get your wood on these girls and [ __ ]
that's where that's uh man all trouble
comes from that bars that's what they're
talking about
well
also the drinking's awesome the way
christianity evolved and the way it
really was on the ground was very
different from what people would have
you believe today
you go through
the histories of the medieval
europe
most of the
church records will show that
the church had a hard time convincing
your average person to even listen to
them
well yeah i mean that's the reason that
most of this [ __ ] came about because
most people were like man [ __ ] off with
it
yeah
so they had to come up with like new
better stories it's all marketing yeah
all marketing well there's a lot of
church stories that have come up that
have been passed down you know from like
the year 1100 1300
what the where you got priests for the
catholic church saying these peasants
are out of control they're [ __ ] each
other and drinking and on the work day
inside the damn barns that you know
these girls good for the peasants yeah
these women are having [ __ ] five and
six kids out of wedlock all with
different men that you know and they're
and they're unabashed with it they're
all proclaiming that they're married
and and and it's out of [ __ ] control
these people are [ __ ] sinners they're
not listening to us
and that's what most of it was the
church was mostly kind of ignored
on the ground yeah yeah now history
culture today would tell you that they
were totalitarian that they oppressed
people and that it was all well they did
but i think it was tried most of the
time and a lot of it was kind of like
spotty yes it depends on where it was
and what time they were trying but the
at the the the main body
of of humanity laughed them off
a lot of the [ __ ] that we live with
today
in memory of the time
was kind of like the re the reformation
all right
weird things they started doing things
that were weird even by those days
most of the time between peasants a
peasant just had to claim to be married
to some girl they were married
it's not like anyone's got a check they
didn't give a [ __ ]
yeah
it was weird when the church said no to
get married you have to come to us that
was that was a [ __ ] game changer now
a peasant had to go to the church and
he'd pay and pay them
to get married and then they had to give
him documents
proving that they were married and that
was some alien [ __ ] to these people they
were like they it took a while for that
cause for a while they were just like
well if you just said that and you set
up a household and everyone was like
agreed they were all in this and that's
america then nobody worried about it
yeah they didn't worry about that yet
everything was common a lot
yeah
uh so the church was started to weasel
its way into things and they just wanted
to cha-ching yeah
it really
started to really weasel its way into
every goddamn thing until the 1700s
which caused a lot of the [ __ ]
fragmentation and people running
like the the new world got got
uh basically [ __ ] populated by people
running from the churches because they
were from different sects and they
didn't want to [ __ ] pay homage to
those other sex so it was better to get
the [ __ ] out
which helped expansion into the new
world
those quakers and [ __ ]
the people that were calling were
colonizing uh the the new england
colonies
they they weren't
they weren't the normal religions of
europe
they were the ones that were kind of
saying no
dissenters yeah they're protestants
they're protesting
there's a lot of different kinds of
protests protesters too german ones and
dutch ones and different types of
british ones and
you know which to for me that's all
great man [ __ ]
you do you you know what i mean don't
listen
they were kind of against large
organized religions because it was
imperial it was like federal or imperial
religions
the the catholic church
well like i said all they were really
trying to do was take your money yeah
they wanted your money in power yeah
yeah they wanted you to pay them for
permission they wanted you to pay them
to go to heaven
yeah that that was a whole racket they
had going there hey come see jesus's
foreskin
and give us all the money yeah what do
you mean you're going to heaven how much
money have you paid us to give me a
dispensation
how much money have you paid us to to to
free you of your sins zero oh where
you're going to hell
that's the only way you're going to
[ __ ] heaven is if you pay us to
forgive yourself
okay
you'll go to heaven now
like i said it's a good scene it's a
grift it's like scientology
it's like everything it's like
everything well like i said they're all
kind of like that they're not they all
just like watch [ __ ] about it yeah and
and and make no mistake these
politicians and these corporations are
like that too they're just like that
grampur's hammer says trust me when i
say the government is too incompetent to
pull off a grand conspiracy yeah i i
kind of agree with you yeah um i'm i'm
more of like the person like um that's
why i don't worry too much about
conspiracies or these big worldwide kind
of things i'm like people are too stupid
to pull that off yeah but there are
powerful people trying to mix there are
but that will never really get any grip
or traction in reality on the ground
that's why i've been in big military
units before what a general says rarely
ever happens on the ground
that's just you know i mean by time it
trickles down anybody that's worked in a
medium to large size corporation knows
that it never actually happens no yeah
everybody's just like yeah there's
people that are supposedly running [ __ ]
yeah and they're kind of pretending to
run they don't know how to do anything
because they've never worked in like
doing actual things
um
so everyone just kind of ignores them
yeah and they're also trying to justify
or just kind of like works around yeah
they're like well we'll do this like to
make them happy but we're not really
going to do this
and that's just how [ __ ] works it's just
like everything is like working around
the stupid people that don't know how to
do anything you know that's just no
experience that's just kind of how
oh my god
for those of you people who think the
military is super competent no i served
in it the higher you go up the chain of
command the more the incompetence gets
worse
the worst ones are the generals
that's just where they hide their
[ __ ] that's where the rich people
send their flunky sons
well like i said companies are like that
too like usually it's kind of like what
do they call that the peter principle
where you're where you go high enough in
the company where you're like kind of
like
what's how does it go
you get to the point where you just like
you're incompetent it's not killing
anybody but it's not like doing anything
useful either that's just kind of where
you get to
tammy's saying uh yeah women in their
hysterical uteri i know aren't like
we're the [ __ ] worst we're the cause
of all the problems in the in the world
danny rolling ghostface says uh huskar
houska castle would make for a good
paranormal show topic as well honestly i
have put that in the patreon poll like
three or four times and it never wins
but we'll get around to it eventually
because i'll keep putting it in the poll
every week or two talking about
paranormal i got a message from um
a subscriber a um
a pretty big podcast talked about mouth
mountain poltergeist last night i can't
listen to it i don't have the app
but they they were talking about my case
right along with the um
um
uh what which one was it
it wasn't it wasn't um was it enfield or
it wasn't enfield amityville it wasn't
amnesville it was the next case oh that
was just the girl rolling doe or yeah
yeah
it was the boy the boy the boy the boy
that had the poacher guys
and uh they loved they loved the book
evidently
and uh i gave word back says we don't
really have time to track them down
but if they approach us and want us to
come on as a guest we'd be more than
happy to be there if they set it up we'd
have to set up the [ __ ]
oh what you call it well i can skype
them
like that because i've done that but
we're so busy around here you know what
i mean i mean they gotta they actually
gotta want us to be on before
well after halloween is over i think
maybe it won't be quite as busy i just
kind of feel like i mean the week of
halloween i even okay i can't even
imagine nowadays i was thinking to
myself oh i'm gonna do like an extra
movie review for every day of october
yeah what the [ __ ] was i thinking
because just doing these extra movie
reviews the week of halloween is kicking
my ass yeah um i mean i'm doing it i
only have like i've recorded all but one
so i still have one more to do but i did
the one for tomorrow already so that's
going up tomorrow
but i mean i'm having fun doing them but
i'm just like man this is a lot of work
and honestly too the book review that i
was supposed to do this week
i was supposed to do house of leaves
because i started rereading it
but then yesterday i said to myself oh
my god i am never going to finish this
in time to put the thing up so what i
decided to do was i have a shorter book
that was sent to me by a publisher
and uh so i'm going to do a review of
that instead and then push house of
leaves back another week because there's
no way i'm going to finish it in time
and i don't want to rush the subscriber
who uh reported it to me was david craig
i want to thank you david the show is
called astonishing legends
the true story behind the exorcist part
1 on
stitcher okay well there you go
astonishing legends yeah it's roland doe
or ronnie manheim or something like that
they call i don't know what the kid's
real name is but that's because he's
always uh gone under a pseudonym but
yeah that was the story that the uh the
exorcist was based on and like um what's
his face that wrote the book god damn it
oh my god it just went right out of my
head william peter blatty
um he actually read
an article about that kid and it was a
boy like i said it wasn't a girl but um
i think it happened in the 40s right
1949 i want to say it was 1949 and that
was what gave him the idea for the novel
of the exorcist it was like a boy
um damon also says uh thanks for
answering you're welcome another
question for tom and jenny have you ever
read the protocols of the elders of zion
uh i haven't but i've heard of it yeah
i've heard of it that be hard to find
it's uh well it's um it's a hoax is what
it is um
it's not what it's purported to be
because i remember reading a lot of
stuff about it although i've never
actually read the actual thing
but um i can't comment i've never read
it i don't know anything about it
i just know that um
it was supposed to be something that uh
you know i mean i don't know if like the
the the nazis claimed that it was real
and saying that it was a real they did
but it's not saying that it was to like
overthrow the western [ __ ] world and
everything um yeah i don't know anything
about it it's fake i'll tell you this
they thought it was real though they
probably did
um
i when i was in the army i went to
israel i had a good time there and the
[ __ ] uh the israelis reflected some
of the
some of the [ __ ] best soldiers i ever
[ __ ] worked with some of those dudes
who were [ __ ] working in some of
those areas like [ __ ] uh what was the
name of that what was the name of that
[ __ ] place
oh [ __ ]
not jericho i don't know what it was
kyber pass no it wasn't cairo anyway it
doesn't matter
um
the problem with a lot of these neo-nazi
type dudes
is uh and this is a this is a problem
really with everybody really is that you
cannot treat people as monolithic
not all jewish people are the same they
got them of different
political bins
they're not all the same do they have
jewish communists yeah they got jewish
communists a lot of the early communists
were jews
but not every jewish person is economy
what are you talking about they got guys
on the right and the left and [ __ ]
you know i mean they're they're a
diverse people so just because you have
some jewish guys or a communist that
promote that that doesn't mean that all
jews are communists that's that's that's
well i mean that should go without
saying yeah but they've got people that
don't think that way you know what i
mean they say well well it's easy and i
see this a lot i see this a lot
um that what x group that isn't like me
um all of them are the same yeah yeah
yeah right and that is never ever the
case no it's always but just approach
people as individual people not with
black people white people please do not
generalize about anybody
because here's something else here's
something else
there are people that are saying that
well we're all the same well if you
start thinking that we're all the same
then the next thing you know where you
can you can think like that oh well if
we're all the same then those people are
like this and they're all the same no
we are all different
life will be a lot easier for you if you
start thinking of people let's see the
things all different people everyone is
an
well i think people misinterpret right
when people say something like oh
everyone's all the same they don't mean
oh everyone's all the same and they
should all be treated like harrison
bergeron type of [ __ ] yeah they mean
everyone should be treated like the same
respect that's what they mean that's
what they mean when i say that that's
like shorthand for just treat everybody
like a [ __ ] human being you
[ __ ] that's what i mean yeah i
don't mean literally everyone's the same
because obviously that is not true but
you got people that are you look the
average person is 100 iq okay
if you say everybody's the same then
then you what you're telling them is
that everybody thinks like me
and if they don't think like me then
there's something wrong with them
because everybody's supposed to be the
same
it's not a good way to go through life
everybody's different
everybody is an individual
treat every person as an individual and
and your relationship with them is your
relationship and then
you don't bring other people into it
it's not
you know what i'm talking about that's
how i look at things everything is on
you treat each person
according to their character and who
they are
well yeah and i think that was one of
the things like when we maybe like
brought this up a little bit like
tangentially like on the incel show i
think the problem that a lot of those
intel type dudes have is they see women
as a monolith he's a model that's a
problem women do this right they all act
like this i'm like obviously that is not
the case
obviously right um you know and that's
obviously true of everybody
so i don't like approaching people as
though
they're all the same or you know they
all people like this act like this i
mean obviously that is going to blow up
in your face yeah
yeah it's like you know
people probably heard me say i don't
like those dudes from the [ __ ]
frankfurt school and [ __ ] he's oh well
he's anti-semitic those were all jewish
guys
yeah but [ __ ] i like john millius he's
my favorite [ __ ] director and me and
[ __ ] amelia's could [ __ ] hang out
john millius ariel sharon
[ __ ] michael michael malus you know
what i mean i like [ __ ] certain kinds
of dudes i don't really care what their
ethnic backgrounds are there's a certain
kind of dude irish respect there's
another kind of dude i don't respect you
know because i don't like what i don't
like the way they think i don't like
what they believe in
but you know what i mean so i'm looking
at people based upon who they are and
how they are
that you know which that's it life is a
lot easier when you go through it that
way just like i said approach everyone
is that they're a human being because
they are they're all individuals you
know like i said it shouldn't
necessarily monolithic people but
apparently it does yeah like you know
[ __ ] it might be some black dude i don't
like you
ross because you're white like like all
white people are the same they're white
dudes i can't [ __ ] stand
you know it's uh no we're not all the
same
i mean you know that's it right that's
what i mean yeah
um what oh one thing i was gonna say
before i forget and before i get too
drunk to pronounce anything
uh we got another present yeah guys
this is from
this is a place called concept cafes or
concept coffees
and this here is an espresso
called demon sway yeah and this right
here
is i didn't realize but they are local
to florida winter park yeah so we're
sponsoring them right now talking about
this coffee this coffee does look good
unfortunately we haven't we just got it
we haven't tried it but when we try it
but yeah i mean it's got dark chocolate
almond and citrus in it so
i'm all about those flavors and i'm
really excited to try this yeah i got a
message on facebook and they were like
hey you want some bag of our coffee and
i was like [ __ ] yeah are you kidding me
i love coffee but yeah i didn't realize
that they were winter park [ __ ] man i
used to live in winter park i had an
apartment in winter park a couple years
ago before we moved in together that's
only like a few miles from here so yeah
conceptcafes.com
go check it out they have like some nice
some nice coffees i'm gonna have some of
that tomorrow morning because it's
saturday but uh you keep talking because
i'm going to the bathroom yeah
um then zach jumps in [ __ ] i forgot
about this jackson zach jumps in talking
about how hot
jewish guys are yeah
zach sacks are real luck he's a real fan
of them jewish guys i think he dates
jewish guys gay gay jewish guys
um
jeremiah's going gay gaza ramallah no i
think now that i think about i think it
was jericho
i ran into some paratroopers and and
they were serving i believe it was in
jericho this is it was met him at a
yacht club in a lot a lot israel
um
i was there for a couple days it was me
and and some other uh dudes we were
there on the mfo mission multinational
force observers we were this kind of
like a u.n backed mission
enforcing the peace treaty between
israel and egypt that carter set up
and uh no we had a good time in israel
man [ __ ] israel had [ __ ] really
good clubs good music this is back in
the 90s um alcohol was good food was
good
they had dietary laws like we went to
pizza hut i tried to get pepperoni they
looked at me oh no no we don't we don't
have any kind of pork here and i said oh
yeah i forgot
so you could only get you couldn't get
any beef with cheese because that
violated a dietary law and it says you
can't get beef with cheese like no we we
don't we we can't serve
uh cows cooked in their mother's own
milk and i was just like
i never looked at it that way that's
silly but i never looked at it that way
but
actually later on very specific yeah
it was turned out they were i think it
equated to witchcraft really back in the
old days but then he moralized it
well a lot of people wanted cheese on
your pizza it had to be with shrimp
i don't have to be a vegetarian i don't
have a problem with that so uh that's
that's what you can put shrimp on my
pizza yeah
because we had that or just vegetables
yeah there's a lot of good israeli food
though
oh he did egypt too
um and also uh sinai peninsula
but out of those three zones man
a lot and [ __ ] tel aviv
and uh where else was that we went in
egypt versus in israel it was all it was
all good the clubs were [ __ ] great
and there was some kind of alert going
on at the time and we went to the second
rave club
and they had uh
girls out there
[ __ ]
just scantily clad tube top hotties
out there dancing and they had [ __ ]
um
m16s and [ __ ] um m16s and um
i think
and uzi's [ __ ] strapped on their back
with pouches of ammo just in case
because they had certain alert statuses
they were all um
um reservists reservist and national
guard
people think oh man you can't have
people with automatic weapons and
[ __ ] bars and [ __ ] oh my god it'd be
a bloodbath just go to israel [ __ ]
guns everywhere
guns and alcohol being mixed
and and [ __ ] teenagers and [ __ ]
it was just normal
just felt like [ __ ] mississippi
heaven it's like being in the south
kind of kind of no they wouldn't even do
that in the south
probably not wouldn't even do that
because they would be like yeah you
can't be in the [ __ ] discover the
[ __ ] uzi on your back you could in
israel
and now i can't believe like how [ __ ]
loud the wind went inside
he seems i don't know if i'm just cause
uh because we're on the second floor i
don't know it's this very very weird
yeah
israel had funny breakfast though
see okay can i can i say like i said i'm
really interested in food history but
i'm really interested specifically
in why certain foods are acceptable
breakfast foods and certain foods aren't
and it's different across cultures
you know what i mean they had and that's
really really interesting to me bagels
okay bagels that's right poached eggs
okay fine fish
a little weird but okay yeah there were
different kinds of salted fish and
poached fish on the bagels
um well that's like uh yeah they do like
lots like black locks yeah yeah it's
like that that's not weird
i think they had uh
spinach
spinach for breakfast
this is uh 1993. but you know is there
1993 trying to think what else they had
it was all of it was in steam tables it
was all kind of watery but this is
[ __ ] hotel breakfast so you're not
talking about the best breakfasts you
can get yeah you know what i'm talking
about um
and there were stuff like they were
drinking stuff like yogurt and tea and
[ __ ] had coffee and yeah
you know it was it was it was good it
was good it's just uh
their tastes were a little different
than american taste no real nothing
really spicy
well i mean i don't know about you but i
can't eat really well i can't eat really
spicy [ __ ] ever because it [ __ ] my
stomach up but i especially can't eat it
first thing in the morning i can
man [ __ ] i can't if i did that but
honestly i can't even really eat until
noonish yeah because even like i get up
in the morning and i have a couple cup
you know a couple cups of coffee and
then my stomach's just like we really
doing this i
can't really eat so it's just kind of
like
you know what i mean i love breakfast
food though and uh mango is bringing up
something about cake yeah i do kind of
feel like we can't really judge because
in the united states
uh some countries would argue
that we just eat dessert for breakfast
oh they're foolish like for no just like
but well because like for well if you
just eat a donut i mean that's obviously
like a piece of cake that's not truly
breakfast a donut is not breakfast
well i know that i'm not going to eat a
doughnut well i have done but
i get it
donuts pancakes waffles it's very sugary
i get it i've been all over the world
and even some of the muffins they sell
over here are basically like cake
then all the
best breakfasts in the world are
american or british which are very
similar
and then right behind that yeah i want
some [ __ ] eggs [ __ ]
right behind that would be a brazilian
breakfast
but it's very different than our
breakfast their breakfast is like french
bread with real butter
fresh fruit
coffee and uh orange juice see that's
good for breakfast
i mean i've eaten that before with just
like just bread and butter and fruit and
coffee that's rarely ever have anything
like eggs or bacon with it it's just
bread and fruit and juice and coffee
yeah which it works fine
now brazilians will translate right over
into american breakfast they like that
too they like they get it
they get it immediately they're like
okay yeah yeah
you know
now i like a redneck breakfast that's
where you take some pancakes and you put
eggs on them and bacon in the middle
like a sandwich and you're dipping it in
the [ __ ]
dipping it in
in in syrup
maple syrup i haven't done that in a
long time
honestly i love pancakes and waffles and
stuff i love all that breakfast food
yeah but a lot of times like my stomach
can't take eating it in the morning yeah
i like that for dinner or the middle of
the night after i've been drinking it's
good then when we were in the army not
in the morning though when we were in
the army we would try to get in and out
of breakfast chow hall as soon as we can
so we can get back and get another
[ __ ] hour of sleep before [ __ ] you
know the duty day started
and we would run in and get an omelette
order order the omelette they'd cook it
up they'd give you the omelet and you
get two [ __ ] things uh
or one depending on how big the [ __ ]
pancake was if there's one big pancake
you get one big pancake put the omelette
in the pancake put syrup and butter on
it and then roll it up like a burrito
and walk right out of the [ __ ] chow
hall eating it
omelette rolled up in a pancake see like
i said
the drunker i get the more delicious
that sounds yeah it's [ __ ] but first
thing in the morning my stomach can't
face it
i can't i have a hard time eating yeah
like i said i can have coffee yeah and
maybe a bowl of oatmeal yeah but i can't
i love breakfast food and i i love the
idea of like a massive breakfast like
eggs and grits and pancakes and [ __ ]
it's like i always want that but i can't
eat it in the morning my stomach can't
take it
i have to eat it like in the middle of
the night
this is why
like if we go to mannequins or something
like that like on the way home we always
go to ihop
because
even that one even that one time when it
was closed but we still walked in yeah
we should have made our own [ __ ] [ __ ]
but yeah so it's i like the idea of it
it's just my stomach can't take it
before about noon or so
but uh you know it's it's kind of it is
what it is honestly yesterday you made
me a burger with a fried egg on it and i
was very i was very happy about it yeah
it was very good i love a fried egg on a
burger kind of salad lily said you look
cute thank you
thank you because
bee's nest is he's back he's not doing
so good
[ __ ] man you're all right three days ago
he hit three days ago he had a surgery
with his mouth and he took took out some
jawbone she's his nephew
three times yeah
oh yes he's it's all small it looks got
double chance i may i guess you didn't
make it to uh
mexico then
see we're waiting to see on when we're
getting paid say we're both on that va
va retirement
and my money didn't come and his money
didn't come so he might have to go with
monday well you gotta wait till monday
might go away well that's what i mean
it's like sometimes it's always awkward
like when the first falls
right around a weekend yeah you're never
entirely sure am i going to get the
money on friday or am i going to get it
on monday i think it'll actually think
it'll be in there this i think it'll be
there midnight well if you check after
midnight i think it will be there maybe
tonight because like i said the first is
on
i can't believe halloween is already
yeah i feel like i've been so busy that
i haven't really got a chance to like
enjoy it yeah you know what i mean that
bums me out halloween's my favorite oh
well
it's always next year
but you know
yeah like i said i just i was trying to
think of because it's not actual
halloween but it's like you know friday
before halloween and it's kind of like
the sidetrack show so i was kind of like
well i feel like i should probably dress
up but i didn't have time to like go
whole hog with it yeah then i remembered
i had this dress and i was like well i
guess i can just do wednesday adam does
that be super easy jay bird's in there
going he's agreeing with me about all
the free stuff the jelly in the hot
sauce yeah
yeah if you ever go to awards and you
gotta be a real red dog to go to [ __ ]
wards you go to wards and you get you a
[ __ ]
sausage biscuit
and while you're in there you [ __ ]
hit it with that louisiana hot sauce and
put a whole packet of that [ __ ]
jelly grape jelly on top of the sausage
it gives you that spicy sweet and spicy
glaze it's like ham glaze or something
yeah i get it it's free
it's not my favorite but i get it i'm
not gonna put a hot hot sauce on
anything because then i'm just gonna get
heartburn but you know what i mean it's
good my digestion is back in my biscuit
i haven't made biscuits in a long time
honestly i would argue and like i said
the drunker i get the more like
breakfast food
this is one thing i always said like
downtown orlando because we'd always be
like out drinking at you know eye bar or
barbarellas as it's called now used to
be called
and uh so we're there and i'm just kind
of like why doesn't somebody open a
24-hour breakfast place like right
across the street and there's a taco
place over there there used to be a
chinese place i'm like all i want when
i'm drunk is [ __ ] eggs and like
breakfast food and nobody has that so
it's almost kind of like so we'd usually
have to like drive all the way back home
and then we'd have to go through
mcdonald's
and then we'd get like i'd get a sausage
egg mcmuffin or whatever because that's
what i always wanted but then they
stopped doing breakfast after
midnight or whatever
and i was kind of like what i have to
get a burger now [ __ ] this [ __ ] i wanted
eggs goddamn it
they just they [ __ ] me over they
[ __ ] me over but at least we have ihop
now so last night we watched um
we just bought it on blu-ray yeah fye
the other day for 4.99 yeah
and uh i love amityville horror it's
still a good movie but it's so funny how
a movie that's so simple it's so
there's not a whole lot to it a movie
that was so simple was so influential
in the 70s and the 80s
that that movie scared this i mean it
was a massive [ __ ] cultural
phenomenon i mean it was mostly like
because of the book which i also read
the book by the way
um i had checked the book out of the
library when i was a kid because i was
all into that [ __ ] even when i was
little yeah the jay hansen book
and
you know just like everybody else you
know i was a little kid and i totally
bought into it oh my god this [ __ ]
really happened holy [ __ ] yeah
and then i think i saw the movie i
didn't see it in the theater because i
was only seven when it came out in the
theater i think i saw it on cable
a year or two later so i was only eight
or nine when i saw it that scared the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of me holy crap but you
know what scared me the most the opening
scene
with ronnie defeo shooting all his
family members yeah oh that oh that
freaked me out so bad and like i said
that could really happen that's like not
even para well that did really happen so
that's not paranormal so that freaked me
out the dream
that uh
j that um
that what's his face has where he's
axing his wife to death she has a dream
right she has the dream where yeah like
where he asks the little girl and then
he like kills her with an axe that
scared the [ __ ] out of me the only
paranormal thing that scared me in that
was the jody thing like looking out the
window and seeing the red eyes because i
don't know if i ever brought this up
before but when i was a little kid i
mean little enough that me and my little
brother who's how much younger is he
than me i think he's four years younger
four years younger and uh we were in
like uh bunk beds
and
i remember waking up in the middle of
the night and looking out the window and
there was legit and i'm not even making
this up there was a pair of red eyes
outside the window okay
and i screamed my [ __ ] head off i
think it was a cat i don't know my dad
went outside with a rifle and everything
yeah and he couldn't find anything
oh it was probably like a raccoon no i
was awake um and i'd been awake for a
little while i was just kind of like
yeah whatever and i looked at the one i
was like oh my god holy [ __ ]
so yeah so i made him go outside and my
dad go outside with the gun and
everything like right he said well maybe
it's a raccoon or whatever but
i don't know if i had seen amityville
horror at that point but so i don't know
but that [ __ ] really traumatized me that
whole red eyes outside the world yeah i
mean you know
i mean i got up to like 13 or 14 and was
always kind of
you know
kind of not really wanting to look
outside a window at night especially
when i was down in mississippi it was
dark outside yeah because you might see
some eyes looking back at you might see
jason with that damn bag on his head
looking back at you something like that
so you never know didn't really want to
look outside the window when it's dark
even nowadays and [ __ ] man i'm almost 50
at this point yeah you know you get up
in the middle of the night to pee as you
do more often as you get older um and
thanks for performing that no i'm just
saying and uh so you get up and it's
like even now i'm kind of like well
i'm just gonna like not look out the
window because you never know if
somebody might be like
[ __ ] looking i don't know i don't
know it's dark inside if it's dark
inside it's dark outside lookouts when
it's light inside and
you can't see outside that's yeah and
honestly i'm not really that bothered
nowadays because like you know we're on
the second floor so i'm like well some
[ __ ] outside now like a face
outside now that shit's paranormal
because he's floating so you know so
it's a you know a lot less scary i guess
so it's like well it's just a ghost it's
probably fine but you know it i don't
know it's just like so that kind of i
don't know that bothered me and i was
like watching it again last night
because i said there's one scene in
amityville horror
where
uh right where uh james brolin is
starting to go like batshit and he's
coming back to the house with the axe
right like he's gonna ask his whole
family or whatever he's doing
and he looks up in
the daughter's window
and sees jody
and i'm always kind of like
ever i've seen this movie a million
times and they're always kind of like
well jody's like a big pig creature
right but
i'm always trying to get a handle on i
can never see it clearly i need to pause
it i looked at it it was just two red
circles
no like i'm talking about the later not
when margot
sees the eyes when he's looking up in
the window and he's like what the [ __ ]
and you can see something moving in the
window it's a pig
and i was trying to see pig i'm like i'm
not reading pig it's like i'm not really
it's just his face what is it i think
it's the face i couldn't see what it was
yeah i gotta pause it and see like
[ __ ] well you could probably see it
online i guess
uh peggy peggy is asking have we ever
seen black christmas yes i've seen it
many many times black christmas is
actually an awesome movie very very
early slasher film not the first slasher
film that would probably be uh bay of
blood aka uh twitch of the death nerve
which is an italian movie but
the first probably
you know it's canadian but
i don't know this is 1974. so it's like
four years before halloween and it had
kind of all the same tropes as halloween
i quite like black christmas actually
margo kitter's in that too yeah i was
talking about she's my favorite
character i was talking i was i i was
sitting there admiring margaret kidder
last night and jenny i said jenny she
looks so [ __ ]
it's just something tom can't put his
finger on it but it's like there's
always some that's why he really digs
margot kidder because there's always i
get what you're saying though yeah i
can't put my fingers in here she does
kind of look [ __ ] she seems like she's
gonna pass you a joint and then jump on
your dick
that's the vibe she gives you yeah yeah
she does that's what she seems like and
i can't explain and i'm not even a dude
i can't explain it to you she's gonna
but i totally know what you're gonna
give you a joint and then she's going to
turn around and then [ __ ] when she
comes back out of the room she's going
to be [ __ ] half dressed in some kind
of real see-through nightie
yeah from the 70s one of those
and then she's gonna jump on your dick
and she's gonna think it's funny
yeah
that's what it's like she's just like
she does look well honestly like in a
good way yeah yeah and i'm not saying
because you know when i was in school
like i knew some girls in high school
that were like friends of mine
and
there is some kind of like indefinable
quality about some girls like some girls
just seemed they and they might not have
been [ __ ] in reality but they just
came across as [ __ ] whether they met
to or not it was just kind of lit they
had [ __ ] energy yeah that's what it is
it's like it's [ __ ] energy yeah it's
like the positive [ __ ]
yeah no not and and like i said i'm not
i'm not denigrating that's not a shame
no it's just like slept [ __ ] are
awesome it's like [ __ ] power [ __ ] are
awesome yeah
she had like marco kidder and i noticed
this a lot more when we were watching
ebonyville horror last night like i said
i've seen it a million times
she has that thing where
and like like i said i'm not [ __ ] on
her i promise i love margot kitter what
is up with her upper lip
and her teeth
well the thing about it is like when she
talks she almost seems like
did she used to have braces i don't know
because she talks like someone that used
to have braces and thinks they still
have braces
you know what i'm saying yeah real thin
upper lip like she doesn't close her
mouth all the way like when she talks
it's like really
i don't think i ever noticed it until we
were watching the movie last night and
i'm like what is that about
you know what i mean she yeah she has
like a really thin upper lip which like
i said that's fine but it's like it
seemed like she doesn't close her mouth
all the way like when she says some
consonants or vowels and it's like and
it's very very strange
i didn't notice it as much in superman
but i noticed an amityville horror she's
also in a great movie called sisters if
you guys haven't seen that uh it's brian
to palmer right yeah she's good and then
yeah she plays twins she's also really
good in that one horror movie that isn't
that black black christmas yeah she's my
favorite character in that olivia
hussey's great in it too she's olivia
hussey's like the final girl but
ultimately the ultimate 70s girl in in
in black christmas yeah she plays like
super [ __ ] yeah she's awesome in that
i [ __ ] love her i was talking about
like all the babysitters like kimmy and
[ __ ] they were they were girls like that
that's what i mean yeah walking around
and [ __ ] they were you know just
talking about [ __ ] smoking weed or
whatever then just drinking it there
they were like that
and it was just like
it's like something that you used to see
back in the 70s
it wasn't definable
well i mean the whole system wasn't
[ __ ] totally it was leftovers from
the 60s and the thing about those type
of girls as well those different women
trolls california yeah and the thing is
it's like i'm i'm sure like dudes like
them as well but like girls also like
them too because like they're fun to
hang out with yeah you could get in all
kind of trouble yeah they were they were
but they weren't
bad they were bad no they were just like
other people that's what i mean that's
why it's like i like reclaim the word
[ __ ] that's not a bad word
yeah it's not bad b is like yeah
[ __ ] are awesome we love [ __ ] but
we're kind of like they're kind of like
guys in a certain way but in a good way
and maybe maybe not really guys it just
i think i think it was just it was
there were a lot of them like that in
california
in the 70s i grew up around a lot of
them they were kind of like dominant
females in a certain way but they
weren't bossy
um they were real femmy in a way
um but well i like it having fun well i
like them i like people like that
because they're kind of more like
natural and not like no [ __ ] no yeah
they told the truth
and i like no [ __ ] yeah that's
exactly what's that that's good no
[ __ ] yeah they would tell you the
truth men or women right
[ __ ] if she saw some dude she wanted
to hit it she'd [ __ ] tell her i'm
gonna hit that if she
was an [ __ ] she's he's an [ __ ] you
know what i mean it's just yeah they
told the truth
like i said i i can i can vibe with
people of whatever gender that are just
honest yeah
i like people that are like honest
i like people that are
vulnerable they're not like afraid to
say embarrassing things about themselves
they're self-aware i like people like
that so i kind of feel like
i don't know maybe that's something that
um you know that i kind of like relate
to with that type of people um yeah
mango said margot is the ultimate lois
lane i said that you said that last
night too while we were watching it
yep
it's it was crazy watching amityville
horror
again after this time because i can't
really picture anybody else as
margo kidder or jimmy as as lois lane
and margot there have been other lewis
lanes but they never quite she really
does seem to be
i mean when i think lois lane i always
think of her
i know there's been other ones i think
it's because you you you nailed it she
was no [ __ ] she was not [ __ ]
well yeah there didn't seem to be there
was no artifice
no artifice i think that's what i like
about her she seemed very organic yeah
and very naturalistic she seemed like um
that was kind of like her real
personality coming through i think it
was she had mental problems on she was a
bad alcoholic she didn't make it long
but i know but there's no uh what are
you gonna do everybody has their demons
in essence that's the way she was
it was like that that's well i think
that's why i always kind of like
connected with her because
that seemed like it wasn't she wasn't
entirely acting that was just her
you know what i mean she got cast in
that because that's the way she was i
think
one of the best scenes and i think i
said something about this to you stephen
king commented on this too like in uh
dance macabre
in that one scene where she's where uh
james brolin comes in and he's like hey
what's up
and she's in there doing her doing
stretching or yoga or whatever she's
doing and it's like she's got a flower
in her hair yeah and like a man's shirt
kind of but it's like open so her
boobies are hanging out and then she has
one it's not a stocking it's almost like
a leg warmer yes but it's like a whole
leg yeah normally leg warmers are kind
of like scrunchy in their leg lovers
were hot in the 70s
but it's weird i was like
i don't know it almost kind of like took
me out of it because i'm like what would
compel you to just put one on being on
camera
because the fact that she just had one
on i was kind of like that's a little
weird what like i'm this is film
thinking as a girl i'm kind of like in
what situation
playboy
yeah well that's what i'm saying it's so
we're kind of coming at it from a male
gaze perspective oh definitely yeah
because it's like a woman it's like i'm
gonna i'm gonna dress myself to do my
nightly yoga stretches or whatever yeah
i'm gonna put on a man's shirt and leave
it open so my tits are hanging out okay
fine i'm gonna put a flower in my hair
just cause and i'm gonna put on a leg
warmer and put it all the way up but
only one well it might have been
seduction
but she didn't but then it was well i
see i
but then like he comes up and she like
acts surprised that he's there so i
don't know if that was like something
like role playing
that's yeah it must have been that yeah
oh i didn't see you there yeah yeah i
didn't know you were coming up here
i
is in there [ __ ] we we grew up in the
[ __ ] same generation and [ __ ]
[ __ ]
when we're
as boys you [ __ ] come across [ __ ]
playboys from the [ __ ] 70s and
[ __ ] most of the issues those [ __ ]
had [ __ ] leg warmers on and yeah
they'd have one or two or one
and they're [ __ ] yeah man playboy was
art art man [ __ ]
girls pretending doing a [ __ ] doing a
shootout or doing it yeah not a shootout
when you call it shooting dude
doing a photo shoot
pretending like they're doing ballet
[ __ ] you're not doing ballet come on
this is a [ __ ] playboy photo shoot
you know i mean it's just the way it was
it was the actual i mean here's okay
i mean it goes back it goes back to the
40s pin-up stuff well yeah they were
doing it too they had one stocking on
the other hand the other stockings like
okay
like you act like you mansplain male
family intellectually i know that male
family but it's like to me as a woman
it's funny because i'm trying to like
picture the situation
where in the context of the movie in the
context of a normal family life that you
would put on
that combination of clothing another
thing that is very funny you must you
must realize
okay here we go okay let me explain some
[ __ ] to jenna all right
back in the 70s a horror movie okay
we're
targeted towards the male audience oh my
god he's gonna mansplain about horror
movies yesterday jenny was one of the
few girls from the new generation that
was watching those things
so
yes horror movies horror horror movie
was synonymous for [ __ ] titties
well yeah every one of them yeah they
only friday the 13th boy
friday 13th part two and part two and
part three if you've been watching my
eekweek series [ __ ] tomorrow i'm doing
night of the demons yeah all kind of
titties in that one yeah linnea quigley
titties yo she's [ __ ] hot yeah she's
a she looks nice well i was gonna say
bush but she actually has a shaved bush
in this one you do get to see her ass
and her uh and her vagina that was she
was a stripper that could act they put
her in movies
you know i met her once at a horror
convention yeah she seems like man i
want to go out and drink with that [ __ ]
she seems like a hell of a lot of fun
in return of the living dead remember
when she did the [ __ ] scene on top of
the gravestone with all the zombies yeah
that's famous that was like man her
level of physical fitness was [ __ ]
and i was gonna say night of the demons
which i'm not gonna spoil too much of it
because i'm gonna put the review up
tomorrow but
there's a scene in that that's almost as
famous yeah um
involving her boob yeah
so
she was a great show how old was she
during uh
night living dad do you think return of
living death
um
no she was mid-20s mid-20s because i
think that when she did
um
when she did night of the demons which
came out in 1988
she said that she was 26 or 27 when she
did that yeah
so i think return of the living dead
came out in 85 so she was probably like
a year or two as far as i know she never
got ugly she was hot way into her old
age she's so hot she's doing well i saw
her at a horror convention probably like
four or five years ago and she didn't
really look all that different and
honestly i saw her on a documentary
about night of the demons and i'm not
really sure how old that documentary was
it wasn't that old
and she i mean she looks older obviously
but she doesn't really look that much
different i mean no what else is funny
look at cassandra peterson she's about
73 72. man we just saw her it's amazing
like i said i saw her on [ __ ] uh that
entertainment tonight or whatever that
show is we saw we were like
at burger king and they had it on the tv
and they were interviewing cassandra
peterson because obviously it's
halloween so you know um but she wasn't
dressed up like elvira she was just like
in her regular guys she still looks good
yeah and she still looks
really young now she's admitted she's
had a lot of facial work well you're
gonna have to get face lifts at that age
but uh it's partly jeans she's tall
or you're a slender at least
and that's
that's anavar she's she's on stuff
keeping her keeping her metabolism
running
telling you if you can afford it people
i'm telling you if you can afford it do
some research i mean there's a reason
why a lot of these rich
celebrities look the way they do
it's it's not by accident
you know what i mean they're on stuff
there are ways to [ __ ] fight it off
now some people [ __ ] fall apart
pretty early
because all them drugs and alcohol they
can go one way or the other
you know in hollywood so most people
[ __ ] fall apart quickly
remember that gorgeous [ __ ] female
that was in a couple of those movies she
was in that one you and your female
female
it was that gorgeous girl was in a bunch
of movies from the 80s she was in that
vampire movie that we saw
which one uh the one that had the the
ones from aliens
most of the caster aliens too was in it
remember
and she was also in a bunch of other
movies remember what was that vampire
movie near dark near dark is that what's
called that they had [ __ ] lance
henderson and [ __ ] disgust yeah yeah
and they had the girl in that
yeah what was her name
i can't remember
she was like their [ __ ] main vampire
squeeze yeah they were using her to
bring her
she looked really good during the 80s
and the 90s and uh they they say the
[ __ ] alcoholism and you look at her
now she just she did not hold a
poor thing
but it was all that drinking
it's weird because like i said
and a lot of this comes down to you know
the individual person because obviously
genetics plays a factor too because some
people can just drink and drink and
drink
and they still like age and they look
pretty good yeah uh and then some people
can drink a drink and then they just
look like a big bloated yeah monster you
gotta be honest though
i mean
anybody even with good genetics if
you're drinking every day a [ __ ]
fifth you're gonna [ __ ] die
yeah that's really not good you're gonna
die of cirrhosis to the liver yeah
eventually and uh on your way to death
you're gonna look like a [ __ ] bloated
ass michelin man
and [ __ ] up looking losing then
and then if you [ __ ] layer in other
things that could go wrong like [ __ ]
diabetes and [ __ ]
high blood pressure and [ __ ] you'll
[ __ ] yeah it'll [ __ ] you up
so
when some when i say sometimes you know
well genetics plays a factor
a lot of times what i mean by that is
somebody's height and their body
composition has a lot to do with
genetics
taller people [ __ ] are more resistant
like they can gain 10 pounds you don't
really see it you know what i mean on a
shorter person you gain 10 pounds it
looks like 40.
yeah it kind of sucks that's so that's
honestly the only thing that sucks about
being a short [ __ ] like i am
yeah both of us is that yeah you gained
five pounds and it looks like a lot
everybody notices
uh you're tall right you can kind of
like shift that [ __ ] around and no one
will notice on the upside if you start
[ __ ] around with anabolics or [ __ ]
trt or hrt you start working out your
frame will fill out a lot faster
you can recomposition a lot faster
like [ __ ] dude like arnie's six foot
four hundred six foot two takes him a
long time and a lot of [ __ ] anabolics
to fill that frame out
not a little short guy
a little short guy could do that a
fraction of the time
because it's only it's only 30 pounds of
muscle
it's just in a smaller part it's on a
smaller frame so it looks like 60. you
know
that's kind of the only upside to being
a shorty that i can think of yeah
because i've been a shorty my whole life
and most [ __ ] is like bad i can't reach
anything
body changes good or bad
happen faster on a shorter frame
yeah
but yeah so it's a two-edged sword
and like i said i can't reach anything
every house has like those cabinets like
that i can't reach that [ __ ] second i
gotta get a ladder yeah it blows i'm
only five foot three five foot two five
three something like that
um yeah gram there's hammer said leg
warmers were a constant in cherie and
hustler not so much in playboy yeah they
both so what oh they weren't classy
enough for playboy i was gonna say that
i had some leg warmers in the 80s
because i was all about i mean if you
guys grew up in the 80s you guys were
all into like the roller skating [ __ ]
right
so i had
some gray
calvin klein leg warmers
and also
remember back in the 80s when they had
those like headbands and they had the
clip-on
feathers yeah remember those
yeah i wore those too so i wore like the
the [ __ ] feathers and my gray
leg warmers
back when i was like 10 and i was like
skating to [ __ ] survivor uh no dermot
you got it wrong it wasn't janet
goldstein
what from yeah janet goldstein near dark
yeah janet goldstein played she also
played vasquez for [ __ ]
aliens too it wasn't that was the blonde
that's what i was talking about
yeah what was her name because she was
in some other movies too yeah god damn
it she was kind of like uh she was kind
of like you're she was kind of like a
generic hottie that they would throw
into some
into some of the 80s movies she was a
hottie
but she was also real heavy [ __ ] into
the partying scene and that kind of she
kind of burned herself up pretty quick
from what i understand she had a bad
alcohol problem drug and alcohol problem
i kind of feel like that happened
i kind of feel like that happened a lot
in the 80s sadly
like i said some people can get away
with it longer than other people but
yeah
it's going to catch up with you
eventually
uh she also played the stepmom in t2
says danny rowland goes face
and she was and she was a lethal weapon
too yeah yeah yeah she was in some other
[ __ ] i feel like was she not also in
saint elmo's fire
i kind of feel like she played rob
lowe's
ex-wife or ex-girlfriend she didn't have
like a massive part but i know she was
familiar i'm pretty sure she was in that
too she was in a lot of movies in the
80s
abby normal's talking about uh cassandra
peterson or elvira she looks so
different in regular mode yeah she's
really like
almost unrecognizable if you didn't know
that was her
that eye makeup and that wig changes uh
the way somebody's going and the way she
like pushes the boobs together in the
dress and everything like that we were i
was just watching um somebody said jenny
why
i think it might be let me see oh yeah
yeah i think that is her name that yeah
it might be
yeah i'm pretty sure she was insane
almost fire as well because i saw that
movie a million times when i was growing
up and i kind of feel like that's where
i knew her from
because i think i saw saint elmo's fire
first and then yeah that's her dark yeah
yeah
yeah that's her yeah
yeah she's which is funny because i knew
a girl named
jennifer wright in high school
so you think that i would have
remembered that yeah that's her
yeah she was in a [ __ ] yeah she was
totally insane almost fire yeah
yeah she was cute back in the day she
didn't have like a
yeah dermott said yeah she was yeah she
wasn't it wasn't like a main part but
she played um yeah rob lou's like
ex-girlfriend or something like that i
remember that i saw that movie like a
million times hey tila's here tina
decided to show up oh my god
making an appearance man we're already
[ __ ] drunk at this yeah where you
been tila
you're in trouble now
[Laughter]
mango says she was also in pink floyd's
the wall
wait what she was oh [ __ ] she was the
girl i forgot about that she was the
girl that blew the dudes to get behind
behind the stage to see [ __ ] paint
yeah man i needed to see that movie
again when was the last time we watched
that i feel like we watched it
no i feel like we watched it but it was
like years ago yeah holy crap yeah she
was cutie
she was actually i've seen pictures ever
recently justin right there she she
still looks pretty good for her age she
looks pretty good so you're taking it
back taking it back yeah
she looks a little she looked a little
rough but she's clean she looks better
now than she did thank you tila what a
cutie good look jenny thank you thank
you thank you
like i said let them [ __ ] flashback
this is my easiest halloween costume
because i already had all this [ __ ]
helping us pay this mortgage
oh yeah [ __ ]
like i said we still don't know what the
bill is we don't really know what the
bills are yeah i'm kind of scared
i did all i crunched all the numbers
though we did it [ __ ] it
mortgage company says yeah yeah we'll
sell it to you i mean it's not we're not
gonna like starve or anything but
it's the electric bill that i'm working
it might be a case where well we're not
gonna be able to like go out we only
have a party all the time for months at
a time because we're like
this next 90 days i gotta watch it with
that credit card
yeah so we got to really cut it down
because my credit card activity has to
be conservative
okay i get it right i gotta get better
than that i'm [ __ ] cleaning it up
it's gonna be all right
we'll do it and honestly i'm not
bothered it's like it's you know i like
going out but now that we moved out here
it's like farther
when i had that company call the [ __ ]
land our old landlords and go yeah we'll
be ready to make the purchase in about
90 days i heard them on the other side
go oh great
[Laughter]
and they're like whoa
because they didn't realize i'd be i
didn't they thought it was [ __ ] and
i says no i'll do it i'll buy it
well because yeah i'll buy it well it's
because our landlords were constantly
trying to get us to buy the old house
that we were in and we were kind of like
yeah eventually we'll get around to it
blah blah blah and we never really did
it it's a good thing we didn't uh
better i like this one better i mean i
liked that old house but now that we're
in this one i like this one this has
more potential this one does yeah it's a
little bit farther out there but this
one's way bigger yes it's worth the
extra 15. and there's like more room
yeah so i kind of feel like this one
yeah it has a lot more potential
you know it's just it's a nice area like
i said it's kind of out in the middle of
nowhere but
see this is more where this came from
put your costume on tom she's trying to
get me to take my clothes off that's how
they do
she's trying to get me to put my down
stripper clothes on
you know you want to do it do i
yeah i don't think i want to you sound
like you want to
you sound like you want to tila says
you're buying the house yeah yeah we're
kind of like i went to the [ __ ]
mortgage broker we [ __ ] did the thing
and
yeah he would be ready in 90 days yeah
well get all your like credit [ __ ] in
order
i had to [ __ ] get the va to pay off
this [ __ ]
nearly a thousand dollar [ __ ] bill
that was hanging over me that i didn't
even know about and the reason why i
didn't know about it is because the
hospital never sent it to me or to
anybody else
and the va was like no he would have
paid this but we never got the bill from
this [ __ ] doctor because they paid
all the other bills
you never got it so then the doctor's
like oh oh okay so then you know the the
my va representative is calling i'm on
the phone with him he's calling all
these different places and like oh well
uh they're like they're
and then the doctors they're like what
the va told that doctor so it's okay
give us the original bill and we'll pay
and he's like oh i don't have it anymore
he says you don't even have the bill
he's like no
he's like so can we pretend that
they were like they're like well then
that means can we just like all get in
on that fiction so then all of a sudden
flicking into the va rep is like all
right tom go ahead and [ __ ] i got
this from here on out [ __ ] i'll tell
you how because they're probably they're
not going to really be able to [ __ ]
bill anybody because they don't have the
original bill
so i'm going to shut all this down i'm
gonna i'll call you back and tell you
how it goes i said all right
i mean if it all works out then like
your then your credit record should be
that'll [ __ ] be a big notch off of
and but the thing is is that i have to
[ __ ] in 90 days three payments in a
row i must have my credit card totally
paid off
so we really can't yeah
like you know right totally paid before
i was making payments on my credit card
but i didn't pay off the whole sump
balance i'd have like 100 or 200 still
on there
all right and that kind of affected my
credit rate i was i was in good credit
but i didn't have excellent all right so
um i have like mediocre credit right
[Laughter]
so
i'm gonna pay it all off by that date by
that due date three months in a row and
that'll that'll bump me up to the point
where i can buy this without even a down
payment
that'll be good yeah tila says welcome
to home ownership you'll be happy and
sorry at the same time yeah um i used to
own a house in daytona so i totally know
that feeling in a way it's awesome
because it's like oh man i can do
whatever i want in this house this is
mine you're right but
every time something goes wrong you're
like oh [ __ ] this is mine
what i worry about is the damn outside
air conditioner units that because that
could uh there's two of them out there
if one of them fails like a product yeah
[ __ ] like ac [ __ ] like the roof yeah um
[ __ ] like that that was always kind of
[ __ ] that i worried about it's like it's
really nice
to own it and know you can do whatever
you want [ __ ] life and no one's gonna
like be breathing down your neck but
when something goes wrong you're always
kind of like man nobody's responsible
for this but me yeah i mean like when my
old house when we had like a termite
infestation
um it wasn't terrible because most of
the house was concrete but the termites
got into like all of the uh the door
frames and stuff and i was like [ __ ]
i'm on the i'm on the hook yeah for this
that's one of the reasons why i really
wanted to buy this because this is a
cinder block house both floors
first and second so very rare yeah and
it's and it's to the new hurricane specs
the doors all [ __ ] open outward open
out right yeah like a damn
trailer
i when i first looked at us man this is
[ __ ] crazy
but
and there's no glass doors
it's all
solid doors
which is unusual for florida florida
usually the houses are mostly glass
don't ask me why
insane people build houses here
the idea is beautiful tropical homes
that you can look out and it's just like
wow you know
but that's not real good for a hurricane
it's not real good for [ __ ]
home invasion either
south florida's [ __ ] got a lot of
home invasions in there
but like i said it's kind of a thing
this is actually one of the few cases
that i heard this house when i first
heard of it because normally even in
florida with all of our hurricanes and
tornadoes and whatnot normally it's like
they'll build the first floor
with concrete like concrete block but if
it's two stories they usually just the
second floor is like just wood and
drywall
um because i guess they don't care if
your second floor gets blown away but
this house
is apparently concrete all the way up so
the second floor is concrete as well
which you know like i said nice so they
built it to like newer hurricane
standards that said though
uh i'm in like this
room that i'm in this office it's right
above the garage i'm on the second floor
and we're right above the garage
and
i don't know like the last couple days
we've had like real stormy rainy kind of
weather and seriously it sounds like a
[ __ ] tornado is coming in the [ __ ]
yeah it's like all i can hear is like
wind
like outside the window it's crazy
crazy
you're saying i'd make a good daryl for
halloween
i got the voice but
we don't we don't have that outfit you
need a poncho yeah
you got a poncho and a crossbow and i
gotta [ __ ] let my [ __ ] facial hair
grow
didn't you think about that for a while
that you were gonna grow some facial
hair yeah and then you wanted to grow
fish in here don't you no i just i asked
because i remembered you saying
something about it and i was like did
you ever do that those dudes at the back
of [ __ ] bar with [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're already
two of them already thinking i'm [ __ ]
gonna try to kill them
why is that
he thought i tipped him you know i mean
or [ __ ] pressured him and i didn't i
just [ __ ] thought he was talking
about me you know he wasn't talking
about me oh yeah
okay and the [ __ ] bartender is like
no honey he's not he's not pressuring
you man you only been to going to this
biker bar like two
two or three times and already you're
like starting fights i wasn't starting
to fight so i was trying to end the [ __ ]
i thought he was [ __ ] talking talking
bad about my [ __ ] armor and my [ __ ]
you know what i mean but he wasn't
talking about me
[ __ ] and then i said all right okay i
laughed it off it's all right but then
he he
he's a little bitty dude i guess well i
see a little bit he's taller than me but
he didn't weigh anything you know
and uh
he thought i was trying to find him i'm
trying to fight him i was just trying to
stay he goes i need somebody to clean up
that [ __ ] that's on the stage it's
cleaning up all that [ __ ] that's on the
stage wait a minute wait what [ __ ] you
talking about on the stage because what
i had is on that damn stripper stage i
had my [ __ ] helmet and my [ __ ]
all my [ __ ] icon [ __ ] striker
armor and [ __ ] was up there so what are
you talking about there's no [ __ ] on
that stage you talk about my armor
and i went
and he goes yeah take that [ __ ] off the
stage and i said wait a minute hold hold
on then he started laughing it off and i
said what are you talking about are you
talking about that because no no i'm
talking about them there's people that
were throwing stuff up on the stage last
night i said oh okay i thought you were
talking about my [ __ ] armor over
there man this is that's not [ __ ]
you know
i ain't gonna let a [ __ ] get
away with [ __ ] like that man not with a
bunch of daydream and he wouldn't even
come here on a bike
see
you come to a biker bar and you didn't
come up on a bike if you came up there
on four wheels you're not gonna [ __ ]
talk [ __ ]
it's just not gonna happen
dudes are such [ __ ] and no no
like go drink and go hang out at a bar
in the middle of the day
and then like somebody says something
that's not even about them and then you
get like all [ __ ] butt hurt about it
no it's nothing
but hurt it's just you know that's
exactly what but
this is men that's exactly what but i
thought he was pissing on me but i was
wrong and then i apologized you know
maybe he he thought i was out to get him
he wouldn't he would i said oh okay i
thought he said we're doing it you know
he thought i was out to get him
you know you guys are so funny it's just
but no when when real bikers are in
there [ __ ] you know what i mean we'll
be running it rolling it you know you'll
like it during the day you need to go
down there like i said i still have to
show up because i kind of feel like
we've got their mama on the back i like
the idea but then i feel like if i go
there yeah
one everybody's gonna be like show us
your titties and i'll be like
no they won't do that okay no and then
like two y'all are just gonna be talking
about motorcycles the whole time you're
gonna understand something am i just
gonna doze off or you have to understand
something about biker culture
oh it says
i grew up in daytona beach okay
i know what's biker culture what's the
difference between an old lady and a
mama
well there's until like that old lady
that's like your that's like your wife
or your girlfriend or whatever like yeah
yeah they're not gonna ask mama is just
kind of like that's everybody's yeah
yeah yeah she's a she's a hangar on
she's a fail okay i'm just saying they
don't ask somebody's i grew up in
daytona they're not gonna ask somebody's
old lady to show the titties this is not
gonna do that they just don't do that
now she wants to volunteer that's all
right you know but they're not gonna ask
all night excited hey man
make your old lady show us your titties
you don't it doesn't do that now if it's
a mama you know what i mean [ __ ] like
i said she's put your mom up okay let's
see let's let's let's let's let's see
some teddy says yeah good update get on
that pole get out of it and then give
her money and [ __ ] like that but that's
it's all fun and games
but you don't [ __ ] with people's old
lady
yeah i know that yeah no you don't do
that
but you know there there is honestly i
just kind of feel like you would
probably volunteer me though no no no
because
that's how you roll
[Laughter]
maybe depending on how much alcohol we
have but yeah well yeah but here's the
thing here's the thing that kind of that
kind of action would be going on on a
friday or saturday night and we couldn't
get in there on a friday or saturday
night it's [ __ ] packed
and honestly if it was friday or
saturday night you wouldn't be there
anymore i wouldn't be there anyway
there's other places to be on friday
saturday i mean they're going to be up
there listening to leonard skinner to
[ __ ] yeah yeah nobody wants to spend
friday there saturday night listening to
leonard scattered i mean you know yeah
but being on there but uh
sunday afternoon that's a good time to
stop in because there's people actually
riding and people show up and then they
got people showing up in full dress and
[ __ ] you know and they got the mama
[ __ ] all decked out the [ __ ] guy
pulls up on us put him in his [ __ ]
70s [ __ ] bell bottoms with his ape
hangers on his [ __ ]
decked out chopper and [ __ ] you know you
got all that going on and then you got
guys showing up on her triumphs and a
few sport bike guys you know they're
just you know having fun that's all
tila asked what's the best biker gang
movie uh best biker gang movie
ooh
you want to say this isn't the best one
but this is the first one a matter of
opinion the first one that i thought of
was the side hackers
which i saw in mystery science theater
my favorite
biker gang movie is mad max one yeah
that's my oh race with the devil that's
also a good one yeah
we did a review of that one not too long
ago
uh i would still go for mad max one and
it's it's because it's not just
motorcycles it's cars
and it's cops and gangsters and there's
not a big difference between the two
kinda and it's mad max in the end of the
world is happening
and it ma and max is still a cop at that
time
and they got a [ __ ] real cool kind of
like sport bike australian sport bike
gang
and it's run by some dude
leader named the tow cutter and the toe
cutter played the immortan joe in
[ __ ] fury road and he got older but
toe cutter he's passed away sadly yeah
he just passed away and his and his
[ __ ]
boys
one of them was [ __ ] um bubba zanetti
i like bubba zanetti that's one of the
best characters he kind of looked like
rob halford with the [ __ ] white short
white hair
and the [ __ ] black motorcycle sport
bike gear and [ __ ] it's just it was just
i remember as a little kid i was in the
damn backseat of the car to drive in
with my parents i must have been about
seven
and they were watching one movie and i
was like man i hate this movie and i
could look over
and see in the other on the other screen
they were playing mad max one and i was
like what the [ __ ] is that about why
aren't we watching that movie this one
is clearly better yeah yeah clearly yeah
it was much better what'd you say you
were watching at the first one with your
parents
some
i try to remember what it was something
lame something that your parents would
have yeah yeah yeah it might have been
something pretty good too but i was
looking at that it might have been for
all i know jaws
yeah i don't see how you be like i mean
i even if i was [ __ ] i'm just watching
mad max 1 and the other screen going why
the [ __ ] are we watching that one
you know what i mean
the car wrecks and the look bad ass
i kind of feel like if it was jaws that
you'd have been like paying attention to
john yeah i'm trying to remember what it
was
because i mean i don't remember what it
was
yeah
man i remember the drive-in
no the wild one was too retro i didn't
really like that one i remember going
one time to the drive-in my parents like
our parents took us when we were little
we had all the blankets and snacks and
everything and they were doing i think
it was five movies and it was like all
night like it was a weekend thing so my
parents were like yeah why not so we'll
go and we'll like hang out at the
drive-in
and the first couple movies were like
family movies or like comedies
whoever was putting together the movies
for this evening
either didn't think it through or they
were trolling because basically they
were like well we're gonna do a couple
like comedies like i think one of them
was licensed to drive which had i think
corey haim was in it so it was just like
this kind of like 80s comedy and it's
like hey now let's play scanners and
those play texas chainsaw massacre too
how about that
so uh so when scanners came on and the
dude's head exploded
my mom was like yeah let's go
because i was like i was pretty little
taylor was talking about sons of anarchy
i saw a few episodes of that and it was
okay but then the longer it went the
cheesier it got for me and i had to
check out it was very kind of
stereotypical stuff um
manga brought up night riders that was
one with tom savini in it
they all dress up like medieval nights
but it was like yeah and they were like
jousting yeah yeah that sucks too that
sucks too but honestly i love tom savini
so i can't i can't disparage yeah tina
uh for the most part i'm gonna say mad
max one
because most biker movies sucked
most of them sucked there were so many
like in the 60s i feel like yeah there
was another australian one that was
pretty good had the same guy who played
toe cutter it was it was called stone it
was pretty good
um
i don't think it was around 83 maybe i
don't know stone that was a good one
that was an australian biker movie
um
but the genre had been [ __ ] up
hollywood really couldn't deliver that
you know
not in the time that they were
interested in it was just 60s and 70s
and they really
they really couldn't get it right
um easy rider
yeah
if you want to call that a biker movie i
call that a biker movie that was he's a
writer was real good
it wasn't about outlaw bikers though
just guys on motorcycles trying to go
through the south and they got [ __ ]
over
um
what else was a good one
i don't know like i said all i can
remember at the moment is like really
bad ones because i've seen a lot of i've
seen a lot of bad biker movies on
mystery science theater because they did
a lot of bad bikers yeah
i would say although the side hackers is
my favorite mad max one an easy rider i
can i can i can stand behind those
uh they're two very different movies
um
but i'd say mad max one
mango says rollerball
not a biker movie
i haven't seen that in a long time
yeah what is that even about like
about some corporate a few dystopian
future corporate gladiators who are
playing like a [ __ ] roller derby type
game oh that's right rollerball that's
right
man oh yeah i remember that one i
remember
uh
yeah we yeah sons of anarchy i think i
feel like we watched
watched some of it started we watched
like the first season yeah or the first
season or two it's hard to get a biker
movie right
um
it would either be very boring because
most biker most biker um
if you want to call them gags i'm gonna
call motorcycle clubs most motorcycle
clubs are not really trying to they're
they're not criminal organizations
they're like we're just riding around
right now there are some guys in there
that make money illegally but in itself
it's not a criminal organization and it
doesn't really have anything to do with
the biker
thing it's just kind of like
we're criminals that happen to be bikers
right the other way around now there are
some
elements and some of some of those
motorcycle gangs have a higher
propensity towards crime than others
um
all the ones that you know that have big
names you know the mongols the hell's
angels
um
uh the ones that we have here uh what is
one's
[ __ ]
they do have a criminal element in them
but it would be kind of like organized
crime to be some of the safer ones
um you don't want to cross them they'll
all protect each other
uh it's just
like i was hanging out with that one guy
there [ __ ] tom's place you know man
[ __ ] we were talking motorcycles and
just they're they're just guys
they're just in another army
and you show them respect they show you
respect you know that
they'll treat you exactly the way you
treat them
if you're nice to them they're nice to
use i'm not i don't worry about any of
that i mean but i'll talk to people from
a drug cartel
i don't give a [ __ ]
you know if
if i'm cool to him and he's cool to me
then it's working out you know we're not
in any kind of business together
i don't care what he does you know
it's the same thing with armies i was in
the u.s army i'll talk to dudes from
other armies you know i'm not gonna
judge this dude based upon what his
leadership told him to do in some
[ __ ] remote part of the world you
know
because he can't control what his
leadership does
you know
he's just another dude like me you know
let's talk about also another biker
movie psychomania
yeah
yeah
not an authentic motor not an authentic
biker movie but a fun
vampire biker movie i guess they're no
they weren't remember
yeah
that has another title too because i
kind of feel like they just put it up on
shutter not too long ago and it was
called something else they were british
rocker
type motorcycles
it's almost like a quadrophenia
situation the russians versus rockers
type thing yeah the british
interpretation of a motorcycle gang was
a lot different than an american
motorcycle gang
american motorcycle gangs in in their
modern form now have are heavily rooted
in the 70s which was the heyday of that
kind of stuff
so some of their fashion is very 70s
i would join a motorcycle gang if it
wasn't the fashion
[Laughter]
you guys look so guys
oh my god
so
um
what was that motorcycle gang hangs out
right it's [ __ ] um
at mannequins
um
warlocks yeah i was going to say it yeah
it's a warlock yeah where we go down
there there's lots of warlocks they just
[ __ ] blend in with the crowd and
tom allows them to wear
colors in the club they don't give any
[ __ ] about it they're they're well as
long as they're not causing they're not
causing any trouble nobody [ __ ] with
them and they're just
dudes and a lot of them have military
and law enforcement backgrounds
so you know and the cops are everywhere
and [ __ ] nobody's bothering anybody
i guess that's their territory because
we only see warlocks there
that's fine
they don't usually come out on weekends
i don't usually see them but you've seen
them a couple times yeah i guess i don't
really think they were there early okay
remember there was that one warlock was
sitting right next to me we're talking
about motorcycles for about a half hour
oh that's right i forgot about that yeah
that was a while back
like i said uh honestly my only criteria
is
are you acting like a douche no yeah
then you're fine yeah and then so far
you're fine so far none of the warlocks
have acted like douches they're just
regular guys really not and honestly
like i said having grown up in daytona
beach my whole life i was born there my
dad's really into motorcycles [ __ ] like
that
um
i would rather hang out with bikers all
day long than spring breakers yes
college frat boys
frat boys are the [ __ ] worst they're
the worst oh my god yeah the bikers at
least although they jammed up the
traffic um at least they weren't
bothering anybody no they're like look
we just want to come into town on the
bikes hang out with other bikers and go
drink
uh they were not bothering anyone else
every time i've run into a [ __ ]
warlock at mannequins he was trying to
hang out
and that's there to go take a leak and
warlock sitting next he's dancing next
to me he's got his old lady up on the
damn pole remember by the restroom yeah
and i'm dancing and appreciating her and
he's pretty yeah yeah i haven't just
said right you know
they're just other dudes that's what i
mean
like i said as long as no one is
actively
trying to be a douche or trying to like
call attention to themselves yeah
because i kind of feel like that's why
particularly in goth clubs because uh i
think grantham's just asked do bikers
have a thing for goth chicks not uh
i want to say yes yeah yeah but not to
an extent
no not like frat boys do yeah it's a
whole different vibe
but biker culture has a gothic element
to it but it does but it's very 70s it
was the 70s interpretation of gothic a
lot of biker mamas have a gothic
even back in the 70s when you looked at
them they kind of had a gothic
motif to them
they see modern goth type
women and they go yeah yeah that's cool
they like that look that's that they
they understand that look they respect
them they don't [ __ ] with them or
they're they're nice to them but they
know that that's a different culture but
they they do
like that visual
there are some of those uh mamas kind of
have what we would call a gothic
industrial look like they'll wear
demonia boots
and they'll have
a corset on or or
it's a mixture of like what we would
wear to a club and stuff that harkens
back to the 70s yeah because they have a
a very strong
affinity towards 70s music
which a lot of gods do too seventies and
eighties stuff yeah seventeen there's
kind of there's a little bit of
crosstalk mixed with country
yeah mixed with countries which normally
gods wouldn't
country but they they like country too
uh but they like a goth look
they don't even question it
they understand it said oh yeah yeah
you know
because they're a subculture they know
we're a subculture
yeah and i
for real that's why i think there was a
difference always even when i was
growing up between
why bikers were always just kind of
chill because they were like oh yeah you
look cool
um
but the difference was with kind of like
your spring break or frat boy type of
crowd yeah they're the mainstream was
they would see
goth people and they'd be like one we
need to pick on those people because
they look like weirdos or we need to hit
on those people because they look like
they'd be freaks yeah um so that was
kind of like so they would fetishize you
or
pick on you because you looked
weird yeah um so either way they would
like actually obnoxiously another thing
and they still do this to this day
another thing that these type of like
frat boy type people do
is that
even nowadays they'll come to like
memento mori
which is like the monthly goth
industrial night at barbarella and
they'll
like they'll go out on the dance floor
and like make fun of like people dancing
or they'll like you know what i mean and
so they'll yeah i counter that yeah so
they'll try to like draw attention
themselves being like woo look i'm like
making fun of the weirdos and all this
other stuff even though like everybody
there is just looking at them like what
the [ __ ]
i do when they see that go up and try to
butt rape them yeah
[ __ ] put them in the female position
be like twerking nothing and they're
twerking and i'm getting up behind and
they're like whoa whoa whoa whoa
and i'm like well what i'm like well
what you were sticking you're right out
there you're dancing you act like a fool
i'm gonna get something
and you know what did you think was it
i'll break that [ __ ] down in a heartbeat
i'm gonna break that [ __ ] down a
heartbreak don't come out here making
fun of people
oh you're gonna get raped well because i
kind of feel like they well
maybe
wherever their whatever planet they came
from um i guess it's cool to like walk
into a club and be like hey i own this
[ __ ] look pay attention to me me me me
yeah and it's like uh you go into a goth
club where you're like the only normal
looking person you don't own that place
nobody is gonna everyone's either just
gonna look at you like this okay they
know exactly what you are or they're
gonna punch you in the face
which shawna will do
shawna will just punch you yeah our
friend shawna will [ __ ] him
and security will just go now you got to
go okay
now shawna you
you've got to go shout a punch to you so
you got to go
you're obviously sean has been on the
show we've had shawn on the show before
yes yes
yes yes
she'll just watch it but yeah and and
tom will just go up to your butt and be
like i'll [ __ ] grind up on you and
grind up on you trying to get up in it
[ __ ] balls deep
if you get there and act like a home i'm
gonna treat you like a [ __ ] hug
you know especially if you're a man if
you're a man and you're going to get up
there in the head like a hoe you're
going to be a hoe just like i said i
don't it's going to be a maximum
security i don't have a problem it's not
even like whatever you look like like
you can dress like whatever i don't give
a [ __ ] like wear whatever you want look
like wear your stupid shorts and your
crocs or whatever just wear that i'm not
happy about it but okay just wear it but
the second you come in somewhere and
think that everybody needs to pay
attention to you for whatever reason
um we're gonna have a problem yeah and
here's the thing
we can get away with this [ __ ] because
there's only like three of them and
there's like a hundred of us
if i start nestling my [ __ ] up into
your [ __ ] booty and you [ __ ] pick
a movie first of all i ain't nothing to
be joking with but if those fists start
flying you're gonna get [ __ ] swamped
with about a [ __ ] 100 yeah everyone's
gonna jump on you all right
everyone it's basically a cult
all right and and once they realize that
that's what's going on then it's not
enough everybody's like who are we doing
this yeah right it's not fun for them
and they don't they don't want to make
fun of anybody anymore see
like i said they only do it as long as
they can get away with it like i said
wherever they came from yeah whatever
hell this is spawned
whatever club they came from
they thought that they were being really
cool yeah but
i don't know you walk in a place like
that everyone just thinks you're a dork
and everyone just like rolls their eyes
because we've seen this a million times
before and it's like
yeah you act up too much you're just
gonna get kicked out or you're gonna get
your ass beat
and security's not gonna say anything
about it because they don't
because you know like i said we've seen
it before we've seen it before
uh time for another drink i think you
want to make it one yeah
okay see what everybody's saying dermot
says good luck cuddling wednesday adam
adams
yeah no one peddles me not against my
will actually they're not trying to
cuddle they're up there trying to
[ __ ] make make everybody look stupid
by them dancing like fools which i don't
understand yeah and it's almost kind of
like i don't
it doesn't happen every time but it
happens often enough
that
i don't know it happens pretty often
maybe it is every time
there's always there's always a group
there's always
at least and it's never just one person
obviously because people don't yeah it's
always like a group of like three or
four people
and it's like they always come in and
they go whoa
yeah and it's you know they're gonna be
trouble as soon as they walk in woo and
it's like oh boy here we go everybody
just kind of like says that to
themselves they don't say it out loud
here we go here's this week's
here's this week's set yeah of morons
you know what i mean it's like let's see
what they get up to and they jump out
here and they do the stupid [ __ ]
dance when they're doing this
and like it's funny because a lot of
goths it's like i know that's kind of
like a cliche like we dance really weird
and stuff but a lot of gods actually
dance really well like they have a good
rhythm and stuff and a lot of the kind
of like frat boy thank you like boy
people
dude they actually can't dance like they
don't have any rhythm yeah and i don't
know robots i just go behind them and i
just start like yeah i'm like do you're
you're not actually like making yourself
look real good you're not making fun of
everyone you're just making yourself
look like a tool that's all that you're
doing
so i'm not really it's like you don't
have any rhythm
so my leg over the [ __ ] i'm important
it's like
i'm like dude you were dancing like the
whitest person that ever existed this is
like it's so sad it's like you're not
even dancing the music i don't
understand what it is that you're doing
yeah so i don't know i don't get it
oh my
god dermot says uh early 80's synth
music is still my fave yeah danny says
danny says this is the [ __ ] wax on
wax off that's dance i mean not all like
i get that it is kind of like yeah i
don't know i don't see a lot of people
dancing like that
so they learned off a fortnight
yeah like the fort it's like some kind
of video game dance that they do
and then go out there and no no no no
you don't come out in the middle of a
[ __ ] gothic and doesn't like dance
what the [ __ ] are you [ __ ] dance that
[ __ ] you know what are you even doing
and expect to [ __ ] get off this dance
floor intact
tear your legs out come here i'm gonna
get me some of that right there
and then they get scared they're like
well if you're gonna
if you're gonna [ __ ] there's like a
forum to treat you like i'm not really
sure entirely
what did they think was gonna happen is
what i'm always mystified by because
there's always like a new group you
would think that whatever little
um whatever little communication system
that those types of people have yeah
do they like not communicate with one
another it's like hey don't do that in
there because you'll just get your ass
beat
i don't i don't really understand why
they keep coming back it's different
ones every time yeah that's very it's
very strange that particular bar it's
filled with [ __ ] gaza and
occasionally it's like a warlocks in
there
that's what i mean i don't know i don't
get it i don't get it
and like i said a lot of them i don't i
don't i don't understand why they think
they're like they're like oh look at me
they're like showing off and stuff i'm
like that but you can't dance though so
i'm not really sure
what
you're not impressing anyone it's like
you just look like a dork so i don't
really know what it is that you're doing
i don't know like i said i'm not
[ __ ] on people that can't dance but
if i couldn't dance i just wouldn't um i
don't like be like
i don't have this weird entitlement
thing where it's just kind of like well
obviously
i'm the awesomest so i'm just gonna go
out and flail my arms around
and look like a tool and yet somehow
everyone will be like impressed but i
don't know i don't know i don't get it i
don't get it
but uh you know
uh danny rowling says uh depeche mode is
my favorite synth could every time be
listened to with or without vocals into
it yeah it's like honestly
i was like
i'm not as into depeche mode as i used
to but to be honest like in the 80s
man depeche mode the cure of the smiths
were that was probably like my three big
ones
in the early 80s
i really like old depatch mode i
actually even liked depeche mode when
vince clark was still in the [ __ ] which
like i said vince clark went on later
with andy bell and like formed erasure
and i'm not i like erasure but i'm not
like super into that that's a little bit
too
dancy to like mainstream for me i like
more like darker [ __ ] but i appreciate a
lot of erasure [ __ ] and i honestly
really like the first
the first depeche mode album which like
i said was still pretty
it's very erasurey if you didn't know
it's called speaking spell um i actually
really like that
but
i like their darker [ __ ] better my
um my favorite depeche model probably
still
black celebration
but
i don't know i could go either way with
that
black celebration probably best the
peshmerd album right
uh i would i would think
some great
reward is cool too violator
that was 1990 [ __ ] man i saw depeche
mode live with uh knights of rabb and
that was 1990
orlando arena that was a long time ago
uh dermot says i love early human league
yeah me too new order xtc oh my god i
love xtc didn't get me started uh even a
bit of early omd oh my god i really
really like omd i had their first couple
albums uh it was the one with enola gay
on it and i had the album that had sewn
love on it and block block block and all
those kind of songs it's like that was a
[ __ ] great album i had that on vinyl
what about
the gothic one hit wonder [ __ ]
skeletal family
remember them they're from school
i don't know if they were like a one
one-hit wonder though because like an
album wonder i guess yeah because i kind
of feel like there was a couple
uh songs of theirs that were that turned
up on like a lot of goth mixes yeah
skeletal family what was that main song
they had uh
i mean when you google them uh that's
the first song to come up [ __ ] let me
see yeah look it up because i can't
remember but there was a i actually saw
them
yeah at the drop dead festival in new
york city
many years back but they had a different
singer yeah
the original redhead was the [ __ ] one
yeah i know and like i was a little
bummed
yeah yeah yeah that's it but there was
another one that was that was on all the
mixes and stuff too that was also good
yeah
i really like it yeah i like skeletal
family yeah
oh let me see
old school goth
yeah
i think her name's uh anne-marie or
something like that and i was like i saw
them on the roster when i went to drop
dead because like i said drop dead was
um like a death rock
an old school goth festival that they
did in new york city a couple years
2008 2009 something like that and i went
to it a couple years in a row and
skeletal family were there but they
didn't have anne marie anymore they had
a different singer but they were still
good and they still did like some of the
old songs so that was cool go ahead go
ahead and pop it in uh uh tila a
skeletal family promised land while
we're [ __ ] doing the show you guys
can listen to that you open that into
another window
i don't want if i can get a uh a strike
not a strike but what do you call it
copyright strike d monetization yeah
because that one time that you should
part of that cult of the the cult video
yeah i got a copyright monetization they
didn't well they didn't demonetize it
they just gave me they were like hey
like
yeah like don't do that okay kind of
thing
uh captain bleido says awesome halloween
attire there jen thank you
thank you very much like i said this was
like my lowest effort halloween costume
that i could do honestly i watched night
of the demons today and i was like oh
[ __ ] i could probably do angela from
night of the demons i could just tease
my hair get a veil
i have a dress kind of like that so that
would be another low effort i don't know
maybe i'll do that for sunday we'll see
but uh you know
er
somebody was talking about omd wanted
dermot says if you leave
bombed in the uk but all the other
singles were massive here well if you
leave that was from
pretty in pink yeah
i liked that song i actually had that on
at 45
young people would be like what the [ __ ]
is a 45 a little vinyl single i had it
on that
and uh but honestly i liked their older
[ __ ] like i said i liked uh so in love
is a [ __ ] great song honestly that
whole album
it had so in love on it what the [ __ ]
was the name of that
i don't know i had it a long time ago
but
i don't think i have it anymore i might
it might be here actually i have a whole
bunch of records here
there's something i can put i can put
the danzig wig on backwards and become
cousin it
oh yeah i haven't worn the danzig wig in
a while that's just so [ __ ] hot you
haven't worn any of your wings oh that's
right you can go get it go get some wigs
it's halloween it is halloween it's
friday well it's almost halloween
like i said i'm like
i'm kind of bummed because like i said i
i always like to do like a big lead up
to halloween which i have done but i
feel like i've been working so much that
i haven't really had a chance to enjoy
it i haven't like carved a pumpkin i
haven't
i see how you got all the wigs i haven't
done any halloween [ __ ] what did i do i
see how you got them there you got them
up on the hung up on those little racks
well those are mostly mine yeah
the black one though that's the that's
the one yeah that's yours yeah i'm heavy
i have one like that but it's blue at
the edges
i'm heavy metal as [ __ ] with this [ __ ]
though there you go
see you can just you can
hardly do there you go see you're glad
dancing
but she just ran over there and then she
looked at him with her eyes all big like
what the [ __ ] are you doing right now
oh pokey
what's more better she's like don't sing
she's like please stop that daddy you're
being weird and you have hair yeah
you're not supposed to have hair pookie
needs a costume i did think about it
i don't know if she'd wear it though
i looked it like every year like chewie
sends me that thing it's like hey get
some halloween costumes to your pet and
i'm always like i'm just like oh and i
always look at it and i'm always like oh
look how cute that is and i'm just like
picturing pookie in it but it's like
she's not gonna wear that [ __ ]
you wouldn't wear it would you pokey she
wouldn't wear it it took us a long time
for a for us to get her to wear a
[ __ ] collar for christ's sake much
less a little costume
but
i don't know
i kind of feel like tom always wants her
to be like a little
you said we should get her a little
jester outfit yeah she's a clown because
that fits with her personality she's a
[ __ ] clown she is like she is a
little clown
oh pooky
you're so funny
and we said that he loves to wrestle
yeah need to get her a little japanese
wrestling outfit oh my god we should get
our little sumo suit uh what no
like those little like the japanese
girls from [ __ ] a stardom official
stardom official a little female
japanese wrestling league and they all
dress up like i don't know like a
twisted sister oh my god that'd be silly
would you like that pokey yeah you look
like a female japanese wrestler
oh my god thank you john robertson wow
that must be 100 bucks huh fifty dollars
thank you so much what do you say i
wanted to tell you guys thank you for
getting me through this rough time i
went through a bad breakup earlier this
year oh i'm sorry about that yeah i feel
like me and tom are long-lost southern
brothers oh [ __ ] impossible because i'm
20. yeah jenny just finished my first
day vampire book yeah wait reading it or
writing it let me know but seriously
thank you so much honestly
it's been like a rough couple years for
everybody yeah um can we bring everybody
down for a second and
don't bring me down you know what i'm
going to say
you know what i'm going to say what's
happening our friend kaley oh yeah
kaylee she died our kaylee died last
night you guys know that is kaylee was
what we
kind of lovingly call our lesbian
daughter yeah we used to take her out
everything yeah she was this little
chick we used to hang out with ninja
kitty though though ninja kitty she was
about [ __ ]
five feet tall 4 11.
and she was a little american come on
cry
yeah
um um to us to us she was just some
little chick
um
to anybody else looking at her when
you're in florida she was like a little
half mexican goth chick and cute as hell
and our friend little swole was [ __ ]
just totally in love with her
and
they kind of dated for a while and then
they broke up and
she married a girl and they were married
even though kaylee was pretty pretty
clear about being a lesbian i mean
yeah
she was mostly she was bisexual
and uh or she pansexual pansexual
we're gothic we don't put labels on
things it's just that's the way it
happened she married this she married
this chick that didn't really work out
that that well over the years then she
ended up breaking up with her and was
going out with another one and then
turned out she had cancer
yeah and died a couple years later she
even made she goddamn it she didn't even
make 35.
and i posted a video that little swell
made of her
as a tribute to her and she's on my face
on my facebook well it's shitty because
the last time
we saw
little swole yeah
uh not this momentum worry but the one
before
and he said he's like oh well they're
doing a new experimental treatment with
her i mean we knew that it was bad we
knew that it was you know
terminal
but we were kind of hoping that they
were doing this new experimental thing
and it's like oh maybe it'll be better
for a while it seemed like it was gonna
something might happen but then i woke
up this morning and her wife posted
yeah that was all of us
yeah
come on
i mean so god she was so [ __ ] young
yeah
little kaley
she died in her sleep
eating up she didn't weigh anything
sad yeah didn't even make it to 35.
like i said [ __ ] man that happened like
when i was younger
my uncle was [ __ ] 32 and died of a
[ __ ] brain tumor yeah
toby said sometimes tonight probably not
no
oh god i'm broke yeah
and now i'm like bummed out i'm sorry i
brought it up
i'm gonna play the video
i'm gonna play i'ma cry though
you made me cry
yeah that was her
poor thing
so
jenny crime
there's me and her
their little swole she knocked him out
it's at the club
making army movies with her
cancer cancer in the intestines ate her
up
went everywhere they couldn't operate
like i said she was so [ __ ] young
yeah they did what they could
beating that man
it's weird we've had that happen like a
lot in the zone lately
yeah
cancer gets them
yeah well we know two other
women yeah one of whom is
my age or your age
uh breast cancer and one brain cancer
the other guys uh i thought it was
stomach cancer
who is very young
yeah i'm not gonna play anymore but
yeah it's bumming me out yeah
we got a super chat there
thank you john robertson just finished
writing it it's in the horror genre my
friend is getting interested in your
podcast mainly because tom's dennis
raider impression
and his sexual problems we haven't done
that in a while you should probably
bring like [ __ ] dennis out
is it weird to think that like dennis
will cheer everyone up or dennis or
we have hh homes up there too hold on
let me i gotta answer all these snipping
messages
wait you got messages yeah we're not
going out tonight
huh we're not going out
i mean
man
i'm drunk and i'm bummed out yeah
and
we've got too much [ __ ] we got to do i
got
i got so much [ __ ] i gotta do tomorrow
yeah like i said it's like
i don't know
why i thought it'd be a good idea
well i know why i thought it'd be a good
idea but i don't know why i thought it'd
be a good idea to like do all these
extra all this extra ship for halloween
because it's like halloween is like the
best holiday so
i kind of felt like oh i need to do all
this extra stuff and then
we had to move and then all this other
stuff happened and i'm like oh my god
this is like so much work holy [ __ ] and
i'm having fun but it's also like a lot
of work but
it's almost done although like i said
i'm kind of behind on the book reviews
so
i'm gonna try and get them up in time
but we'll see
we'll see
camp guy said
life is so bittersweet i know i agree i
worry so much about my kids having an
accident that i just have to make myself
not think about it yeah it's almost kind
of like this thing where
i get into this like this weird state
after
my grandmother died um that
i was like
it's weird because i kind of feel like
when someone you love dies you're almost
kind of like
i can't
i don't know if you guys know what i'm
talking about but it's like i can't be
happy anymore because it's like
not
because i'm not like bummed out about
them 24 7. you know what i mean so it's
like you feel guilty
when you're happy you know what i mean
and i kind of feel like after my
grandmother died i went through that for
a long time because i was like you know
she wouldn't want me to be like bummed
out all the time because i was
and then i was like well
i felt good one day and then i felt bad
about it and then i was like why am i
this is like [ __ ] up why am i feeling
like this
like i'm not allowed to be happy because
somebody died that's i don't know that's
messed up so
i don't know
but i'm just like i'm i'm having
conflicting emotions because look we
knew this was coming i mean what's that
point
we've known that she was sick for a long
time
and
but it was still like i don't know it
was still like [ __ ] up like when i saw
her this morning her name was kaylee i
called her kitty
because she was always dressed like a
cat
well she went by a ninja kitty ninja
katie you guys are kitty
so it's like even though i was expecting
it yeah
when i saw it this morning i was like ah
i knew it was only a matter of time when
i heard the diagnosis of what kind it
was and [ __ ] where it was and what it
was doing to it i was like oh man she's
gonna die
and she did god she's so [ __ ]
she wasn't how old was she 34. 34. yeah
jesus christ and it took her about what
about a year and a half yeah
yeah because we heard about a while but
like her and her wife like moved away a
couple like a year or two ago yeah so i
hadn't seen her in a while i mean i
think they were still kind of together
sorta but because his friends do
yeah because laura was the one that
posted about it i found out about it
because sonia
reposted
laura's thing to me yeah so that's how i
found out about like this morning and i
was just kind of like man i didn't need
this [ __ ] today little swole called her
every [ __ ] day for the last [ __ ]
month and played video games with her
online when she was over there she's
over there in that treatment center yeah
playing video games together
[ __ ] he talked to her every [ __ ]
day and he knew it was coming because he
called her twice in a row on the last
two days and she didn't answer
so he knew she was
knocked out they were keeping her dumped
up
you knew she was a goner
but like i said i mean we kind of a
little small
little swole was like her [ __ ] was a
true friend to her loyal like a [ __ ]
dog
everything that went down between those
two and he walked her right to the gates
of valhalla
he went right with her
yeah
come here
ilsa if you're out there
pookie loves
these treats yeah
elsa sent us these halloween treats yeah
one of them are uh it's what is it
creepy catnip and that one is a tasty
human yeah
she likes the tasty human ones best but
she likes the catnip she knows what the
flavors are according to the color
she'll go bam this one
yeah she's like can i have some of these
please and then she knocks that box over
she knows the flavors by just by the
color of the box she like can you please
pour some out for me yeah pokey yep uh
should be sitting next to the boxes all
chilling out
for like an hour or so and then she goes
i'm ready
yeah i will do some of these please
what does the tasty human look like they
look like all the other ones they're
honestly it says on the back like i
think i read it like on the other show
probably the barbecue flavor no it's uh
there's it's actually several flavors
let me look
because i think i read this on the
wednesday show but maybe people didn't
see it yeah uh it's actually chicken
liver and beef
uh and it says
flavor do not contain any human so yeah
just for legal reasons
there are no humans in this in these
treats but
um yeah pookie's super into these i love
that like the back uh copy of this is
kind of like implying it's from the
cat's point of view and they're implying
it's like if you don't give us these
we're gonna eat you yeah because they're
so delicious but yeah she does actually
like these the best but the catnip ones
are good too
but she comes in like knocks them over
and like wants some
i thought like i said i thought they
were fake and then elsa sent me a box of
them and i was like oh my god i'm so
happy that these are real yeah they're
saying they call us the the universe
called kaylee back yeah she uh got the
coordinates from the navic computer and
made the jump to hyperspace
yeah we're gonna we all see each other
after we go
i mean you know we go outside the space
time continuum
into
into further realms of the universe as
spiritual chipmunks i'm trying not like
think about it
honestly that's why i tried i had to go
on facebook a couple times today because
i was like posting
videos and stuff like you know i had to
post movie reviews but every time i went
on there
everybody
was posting about her and i was just
like this is like it was like making me
cry all day long and i was like going to
the quantum universe life isn't long
anyway it's short for all of us well
i'll see we'll all be in that same
position
we'll all make that jump into hyperspace
and it would be just like they said in
[ __ ] indiana jones the greatest
adventure
i don't know
i'd be happy if i just fell asleep and
didn't have to deal with this [ __ ]
anymore
because i'm tired the buddha said
don't worry don't don't cry for the dead
because the dead have [ __ ] escaped
this [ __ ] life yeah but also don't
tell me what to do yeah but you but when
you feel sorrow it's because you kind of
feel sorry that you won't see them but
you will see them in the void of the
afterlife or whatever yeah but see i'm
not sure of that it won't matter
it won't matter if you die and there's
nothing that's then you won't even be
around to worry about it i don't worry
about it i've had obese and near-death
experiences i'm not afraid of death i
just believe it's a continuation
and yeah you go into a quantum world
outside space-time continuum outside
your own personality it's just you're
just a point of view like a happy little
chipmunk
of the universe or a happy little tree
yeah right you just
have you know and and you're now in the
real universe it's like the internet
the spiritual internet
it's like the matrix
anything you want
i don't know i can't quite i can't quite
buy into that so that's because you
haven't seen it it's a weird out-of-body
experience that you have now you've seen
[ __ ] weird poltergeist manifestations
what i'm talking about you know just
trust me i can't get behind don't worry
about it don't worry about it this is
all the natural order of things
everything
everybody knows that but it's like it's
still um let me finish i don't know i'm
not going to because i kind of feel like
you're still like delegitimizing like
people getting upset about people being
dead it's like that's
[ __ ] up the the
passing is part of it that's part of the
human experience
we um
i forgot i was gonna say don't matter it
doesn't really matter no i was saying is
everything is as it should be
nothing's wrong
everything is as it should okay gloss
yeah
yeah any everything as is as it should
be everything is right
there is nothing wrong in the universe
it's just it's [ __ ] up but that's what
it's supposed to be you just gotta
[ __ ] learn to let go
go yeah
yeah but like i said that can go too far
in the other direction where you can
just become a sociopath and like not
care about anything well yeah well
that's that's really what that's what
freddie friedrich nietzsche
said about it that's what the dark side
of the force was all about well if all
this [ __ ] really doesn't matter then i'm
just gonna do whatever the [ __ ] i want
to do and get what i want
yeah you can look at it that way is uh
but is that you know
that's on you and you're gonna have to
pay for that you know if there is
payment
which i think there probably is
you're just gonna end up tuning yourself
into a different version of reality
you'll just become something that maybe
you didn't want to become
it all works itself out it's all part of
the story
tammy says my daughter sent my cats a
box of the tasty human treats i'm so i
can't tell you
how happy i am that those are a real
thing because when i first saw the ad i
thought it was fake like i thought
somebody had photoshopped it so i was
very happy to find out those were real
and pookie
loves them
so you know she'll eat me if i'm dead
that's fine i'm i'm
i i've uh kind of ignored myself to that
fact uh danny rowling says if someone
donates a hundred dollars tom and jenny
should try one of those cat treats
um i i'd try it for i'll i'll eat one
for a hundred dollars yeah sure why not
they can't be that gross come on
they're all natural i read what was on
i mean it's no worse than like some [ __ ]
that i would eat out of a box anyway on
the back of the cat treat
box it said the [ __ ] if your cats are
eating too many of these things don't
worry about them your cat can eat a
whole bowl of these there well see
because i was worried about it because
i'm like look pookie
she will eat
we have wet food we have fancy feast
that's a good [ __ ]
um and every now and then she'll be like
hey can i have some fancy beast and then
like i'll open it and i'll put a little
bit out and she'll lick it and then
she'll be like meh and then she'll walk
off
however the temptations she is all about
that [ __ ] if you put it on a plate she
will eat all of it yeah and then she'll
jump on you in the middle of the night
and be like hey i'm out of temptations
can you please
refill the [ __ ] yeah so
i was kind of worried because i'm like
she's just eating
only that it's like is that like like
candy i was like is that like oreos is
she's eating a whole diet of oreos i
feel really bad
um but apparently
we're not the only ones who are worried
about that evidently i guess because the
guy's on temptation says no it's just
high quality cat food that's like it's
fine it's like it's got all the [ __ ] in
it it's like they're not gonna die if
they only eat this um you know she might
get i don't know she might get fat
yeah but it says that uh it says that
one
basically one whole bowl of them
has all the nutrients that a cat would
need for a day
which that's about what she eats
i mean like i said she does eat other
things she does eat some i think she
eats some of the dry food
yeah
although beijing seems more into the
regular dry food than pookie does yeah
temptations are just uh they do eat the
wet food but i kind of feel like pookie
just likes to lick the gravy off it yeah
and then leave it yeah i thought it was
like some kind of trickery like they
were giving us cat crack
but that's not what it is they just said
it's high quality cat food that has like
liver and cheese and [ __ ] gravy and
chicken and so it's just it's just a
higher quality of cat food they can eat
it
they tell you that you know yeah they
can eat
eat a whole bowl of them i mean unless
they're just making me feel better about
it no probably right because the cat's
instincts would know if something was
good you know i mean it's it's giving
them something although to be honest
pookie would you choose plastic too yeah
that's what i was just gonna say
she'll eat pens yeah so but that's a
texture thing that's a texture thing
i mean one of her favorite things is
just
she will walk around in this carpet and
just like find some random [ __ ] which i
don't even know what it is it's like
pieces of plastic or styrofoam or
something she was like hey i'm gonna eat
this i told you to eat it
i'm like don't eat that and then you
know
you know how well that goes
sometimes yeah it says i'm getting my
boys greenies yeah she loves them too
yeah she likes her because it's good for
their dinner yeah yeah um [ __ ] yeah
we have greenies also yeah if anybody
wants to send her greenies we can do it
because we can't really rarely see those
around here
i've ordered them from chewie before
also like i said
she really likes yeah she likes greenies
and she likes the sheba
meat sticks
yeah we have a couple like packets of
those because they come like in packets
of like three sticks no it's like a
packet more like six or six sticks yeah
whatever it is and so i've gotten those
and she really likes those yeah it's
like beef jerky for cats yeah she likes
those
and but other than that like that and
temptations yeah mango says some cats
have the habit of licking gravy yeah
that's all she does she just licks that
damn gravy but she ironically eats some
of it
she likes it when it's kind of dried out
yeah it's weird she likes weirdly though
like for a while we thought well because
she only likes the gravy let's get the
fancy feast gravy only yeah so let's get
that and then she was like no [ __ ] that
i'm not yeah
[ __ ] cats are funny
she wouldn't do it no she's like no i
only like the gravy if there's bits of
it that i could leave there yeah and
then and wait and eat some of those bits
when they're dried up when it's just
when you just give her gravy she's like
no yeah i don't like it and then i
bought these packets of thing i think
they're frisky's lickhams and if that's
it yeah yeah and you kind of like open
it and she likes it and it's all gravy
yeah she likes